at the end of time
[Music]
13. o'clock
hey everybody what's going on it's
Wednesday yeah we got a new camera yeah
oh look the microphone's blocking spots
well I I put it up and it fell back down
there we go hey Zach is here good news
I'm clean
you were pregnant
that also would have been funny it'd be
[__] hilarious yeah we rearranged the
um uh room oh it's the same room but we
didn't change anything in the background
that's been there the whole time we just
moved the camera to where it was yeah
um yeah American Military 100 said yes
another serial killer who was a Leo the
story behind Gerard Shafer is
fascinating this guy I'm honestly I
don't know why he's a Florida man and um
I honestly don't know why I didn't know
anything about him prior to
doing this show because this guy was a
[__] man he was a piece of work I
think maybe the reason
is that he was ultimately only convicted
only of two murders however uh they do
suspect that he may be killed as many as
I've seen from 28 to 32.
um his own Recollections are between 80
and 110
um but I don't know and he's dead now so
um so I don't know if we're ever gonna
figure that out because but there are a
lot of cases that they think were
probably him but they couldn't prove it
for various reasons because they hadn't
found the bodies or something like that
so he was like I said only convicted of
two so it's like in that technical sense
he's not even really
considered a serial killer serial he's
just like a suspected serial killer he
says it was about a hundred though yeah
okay which
considering how many they think that he
did Kill I don't really think that
that's too much although he was
he seemed like a bit of an exaggerator
in the same way that he's very much a
BTK type and it's interesting because
just kind of accidentally we ended up
watching
um that uh miniseries that you know
documentary series about BTK that is on
Hulu like it came out last year and it's
uh Katherine ramsland like you know
they're talking about it's kind of based
on the same book that I read that Sophie
sent me it's a good series where she
yeah where she corresponded with him for
like 10 years or whatever and um yeah so
they made like a like a mini series
about it so we were watching that and
and I had been researching Gerard John
Schaefer too and I was just kind of like
man these dudes are like they would have
hung out I kind of feel like if they
were in the same area because they have
a lot of the same
pathologies and a lot of the same this
dude seemed well I don't want to say I
don't know if he was even more
narcissistic and arrogant than BTK was
because that's a pretty tall order I
think it was pretty similar
although I think some of the [__] this
dude said later on was like a little bit
crazier but maybe not I don't know we'll
get into that but it's just I don't know
I just kind of found it interesting that
these two were kind of he's a little bit
of a Ted Bundy type too because there
was
possibly at least according to him
um some necrophilia going on
so um we'll get into that too and I'm
sure all of the horrible [__] that we're
gonna be talking about on this episode
is this is going to get demonetized so
oh well
wtk uh series is good it is yeah I was
and there's a lot of uh there's a lot of
[__] Dennis's voice in there over the
phone and talking and it helped me
polish up on my [__] BTK voice you
know yeah I used to be a monster of
course I'm a monster
hahaha
these worsen up worsen up yeah it won't
worship a little bit yeah all that
Midwestern yeah yeah
yeah okay I was getting into the it into
the uh the Dennis Vibe yeah yeah
well because there was yeah there was a
lot well because like I said Catherine
ramsland wrote that book about him and
so she had recorded like all of the
phone calls and she had all the letters
and stuff like that so yeah well good
evening hello
how are you how are you he's trying to
flirt with her over the phone and [__]
I mean yeah
it's uh it's yeah Tammy says hey there's
Spock yeah we moved him back into the
background I said he's like the mascot
we got to put him back in there yeah uh
hey Dave how are you doing says hello
long time no see live but hi YouTube
yeah you haven't been in the chat for a
little while uh it turns out we actually
did do a live stream on Monday uh review
of the Meg 2 the trench but it was taken
down because Warner Brothers apparently
thought we violated their copyright how
did we could violate their copyright
well that's what I said so I sent him an
email and I'm just like
um how can that be because it's like we
didn't even show the [__] trailer for
the [__] yeah and it's like and I've
seen like lots of other YouTubers that
did reviews of that that used like
little clips from editor from the
trailer or something like that I'm like
we didn't even do that we're just like
two [__] sitting there talking about
the movie and we even liked the movie
yeah so what's your [__] problem
so it's just AI did it probably well
like I said it came from we'll see I
don't know if it came from Warner
Brothers it said that it did but I was
like well I don't know if that's their
official account or if it's just
somebody being a dick or I don't really
know
so
um so I don't know so I wrote to them to
get it like reinstated but it might not
I so I don't know I haven't heard from
them because I was like bro I don't even
know what your [__] problem is like
do you not want anybody talking about
your movies because I've you know
probably fine I won't but I mean don't
go see any Warner Brothers movies there
maybe they didn't like how I described
it being kind of like a like Chinese
Godzilla movie well the stupid thing
about it is like I said I saw like a
bunch of other channels had reviewed it
and a lot of them didn't like it really
and it's like they didn't take and they
didn't take those videos down at least
as far as I know huh
it just seemed weird but I have heard
like from other sources that Warner
Brothers is real uh uh you know is real
stringent about copyright to a degree
where it's like ridiculous like they're
kind of known for it so I don't know
like you said it's probably just like
some [__] algorithm doing it it's
like somebody mentioned the movie yeah
we gotta turn that off do we gotta turn
it off
hahaha
yeah Dave said I went and seen the Meg
too yesterday I just loved it so silly
and fun it was like yeah it was a fun
movie yeah I thought it was cool yeah we
saw it so I actually thought it was
better than the first one I don't know
what those guys are saying that
that it wasn't as good as you know that
the first one was better
no I think the second one was better
well some of the ones that I thought
didn't really like either one of them
but you know what I mean
but um yeah I guess I didn't remember
much about the first one to be honest
with you I don't remember much about the
second one now
well yeah
like I said it was just like a big dump
yeah action movie no but I said the
thing that pissed me off the most you
know I was like oh well if it had just
been the review of
um of Meg too and they took it down I'd
have been like that well too bad so sad
but we talked about other [__] on there
like we talked about adopting our new
cat yeah which you know if you weren't
here for the Monday show we adopted
another kitty so we have three now but
we talked about that and I'm like man
that's that really pisses me off that
they took that down because we talked
about stuff that wasn't even about the
[__] movie that's how you know what I
mean yeah
um
Tammy said what could you have violated
by only talking about the movie that's
what I was trying to figure out and like
that's what I wrote in the thing I was
just like how is it violating your
copyright just by talking about the
movie I was like waiting to show part of
the trailer or nothing it's like what
the [__] is your problem I didn't show
any stills from it the only picture that
I used for it was in the thumbnail and
you're allowed to do that that's fair
use
so I don't know what their problem is
they're stupid
don't go see their movies because
[Laughter]
they probably own everything but um but
yeah so uh somebody wait Camp guy said
lots of killers out of Florida big state
lots of population yeah the heat
probably drives people crazy too I
imagine well it tracks crazy people yeah
a lot of people do move here yeah
because of the weather and like I said
and then it kind of cooks their brains
I think is is one of the things because
we have people from everywhere you know
what I mean and it's just kind of like
if you're in the South and you're crazy
kind of a crazy Place yourself you're
gonna be crazy you're gonna end up with
three places New Orleans Atlanta or
somewhere in Florida yeah that's like
the crazy magnets
yeah for whatever reason for southerners
now if you're new this place attracts
New Yorkers too but they're like
retirees yeah mostly because it's you
know hot down here so they're like sick
of the cold weather they don't want to
shovel snow anymore
they stick out like sore thumbs
I guess you spot them a mile away
Camp guy says Charlie Branch Florida
Keys serial killer we should probably do
a show about him too weird case based on
his Emma the police think he may have
killed way more than the four they know
for sure he's suicided after killing his
wife
yeah this guy like I said I suspect
I don't know I don't know if I'd go as
far as like him because I think he was a
little bit boastful
because he was one of those guys because
I feel like BTK was like this too where
it's like they wanted to be like the
best serial killer they could be which
is pretty [__] up I was like yeah
goals okay so um because he was very
this guy Gerard Schaefer was really into
His Image like he was really into
talking about it's like oh you know I
hang out with Ted Bundy in prison
because I think they were in the same
prison for a while
and um you know and he told me that one
one double murder that he did in
Washington state or Oregon it's like he
was homaging me you know what I mean so
he was like trying to like drive and I
was like even among [__] serial
killers they're like just [__] name
dropping it's ridiculous and another
thing that he said too and I don't know
if this is true or not but he said
Gerard's in
that when
because a lot of his letters if you want
to read because he wrote um because I'll
get into this a little bit but he wrote
like a lot of stories and he wrote a lot
of [__] about
um you know being in prison and
everything and
um he said that when Ted Bundy got
executed that you could hear him like
howling and screaming like a [__] like
all through the prison and then he was
talking and and he said before they even
did it like he was howling like a [__]
when they were shoving the um cotton
balls up his ass like like at all this
other stuff he did that well I don't
know that's what I mean this is a serial
killer talking so it's like I'm not
really sure how much stuff they do that
well that's what I mean it's like I when
I had never heard of that but I was like
well it kind of makes sense because you
know what I'm like [__] all over the
electric chair because you know they did
the electric chair then they don't do
that anymore but um but Ted Bundy got
electrocuted but so I don't know if
that's really the case and he also said
too and I know this is a lie because the
timeline doesn't work out but he does
say that there was a female uh killer
who I can't remember what her what her
name was but um but she got executed and
it's like oh some of the um the
sheriff's guys like at the prison like
let us watch them like shave her [__]
like before they that didn't happen and
I and and then like somebody pointed out
like in the comments it's like um she
she didn't get executed until after he
was already dead what the [__] is he
talking about but uh but yeah so it's
like that kind of stuff so yeah so you
can't really tell but I will concede
that he obviously killed way more people
than the two that he was convicted of
and they know and they're pretty sure
like 99 sure that he did but it's like I
said they didn't and he's dead now so
they can't really
and he did actually confess to a lot of
them like in a roundabout way but yeah
this [__] and he was another one
too just like much in the BTK mold where
he was always trying to get into a job
where he was like in a position of
authority and this guy actually did
become a cop matter of fact that's one
of his nicknames is the killer cop
he wasn't a cop for a long time but he
did use his copness as
a way to get victims so there's that uh
they also called him the hangman for
reasons we'll get into later which are
not pleasant I must warn you
so yeah this is uh this is kind of a
[__] up one and like I said I'm kind
of wondering why this dude's not
better known you know maybe just because
he was only convicted of too but
I mean the story is really really [__]
up matter of fact like one of the guys
one of the prosecutors that worked on
his case thought he was he called him
this one of the sickest people he'd ever
met or one of the most like deviant
people he'd ever met
so that's saying something for a Florida
prosecutor I'd imagine
um but yeah murder Hornet said he
probably had sexual problems too oh yeah
oh yeah this this dude had massive
massive sexual problems and like I said
similar to the ones that BTK had
um you're watching the BTK thing last
night I realized that he didn't have sex
with it he didn't rape any of those
women no this guy did he just strangled
him
and I was I was saying the Geniuses I'd
like to see his dick
why isn't he why isn't he raping them
you know yeah embarrass him or something
yeah it's gonna be like a
it's going to be kind of like uh like a
D'Angelo situation a golden state killer
thing yeah I think so he didn't want to
embarrass himself
that's what I'm thinking because he just
masturbated on him when they were dead
he didn't want them even to see they
didn't he didn't want them to see that
yeah it's so there's there's some [__]
up with him
yeah I imagine there is problems there's
more than more than meets the eye there
um Camp guy said Randy Kraft used to
stuff a sock up their rectums he
supposedly learned to do that as a medic
in Vietnam to keep the corpses from
leaking
uh and crafts victims were all male yeah
I've heard of that guy that's another
guy which is like I said you never run
out of serial killers I know it's really
depressing Mr 88 said he definitely did
kill more than he's officially convicted
of having killed oh yeah big time
um like I said the most official
official thing that I've seen just based
on missing persons cases and
circumstantial evidence and like [__]
they found in his house and stuff like
that they're thinking that the total is
probably 28 but it could be much much
higher so but like I said I don't know
because of all the boasting that he did
and stuff about all the [__] about Ted
Bundy and yeah yeah oh yeah because he
said that he was screaming when they
stuffed the cotton balls up his ass and
then when they strapped his dick to his
leg or something like that I'm like I
don't know if they do that but I mean I
don't just telling good stories yeah I
guess that's what he's doing yeah yeah
but Duncan we were watching uh
that BTK one this little details that
came out man and I thought were [__]
hilarious like they were interrogating
Dennis and they go okay now let's we
need to talk about your male victims and
these like male victims what are you
talking about well we have all those
photographs of those guys that you tied
up and killed and he goes with the masks
and he's like oh no that was me I took
those people dressed up he's like he's
all proud yeah yeah yeah yeah
because they found all those photographs
yeah I've offended his outfits he goes I
got that tripod and I had that little
squeeze ball that hits the the thing of
them boy I really love that I haven't
had to hide it impressed and take
pictures say so be a [__] Dennis is
claiming to have invented the selfie
he did kind of come across like that he
was claiming to invent the selfie well
the way he was describing it he was
describing it like nobody else had ever
heard of such a thing yeah he rigged
that up which and I'm just like ooh
really yeah that's what that [__]
thing is for dummy that's why they make
it it's like you don't have to tell
everybody yeah like I said you didn't
invent the [__]
you couldn't see it I'd step on it you
know
it's like the little clicker thing that
I have for my phone camera right you
gotta hide that too but at least that's
much he thought he was a lot more
creative than he was well he was
definitely thought he was a lot smarter
than he was that's for sure like that
you could tell just like the way he
talks like he always came across as like
real condescending
but it's like that was the funniest
thing to it and it will never stop being
funny to me that he got caught because
he he sort of asked the cops can you
trace a floppy disk and they were like
no of course not and then he and then he
was indignant about it he got him on
camera goes you lied to me and they're
like why'd you lie to me because we're
trying to catch you he's like because I
was trying to catch you Dennis yeah yeah
duh we're like not on the same team bro
and it's just the fact that he was just
so shocked and indignant by that it's
just like it cracks me although I gotta
Hannah did as he was laughing about it
because you know me being a Boy Scout
leader I thought you know
oh and also a serial killer yeah I
always tell the truth I never lie yeah
okay
that's a bunch of [__] right there
I'm like yeah you're relying to your
wife all that time about what you were
up to yeah so
no Boy Scout there that's when the
Minotaur had him yeah yeah they didn't
bring up the mandatory that's in the
book yeah but it's not because a lot of
the stuff from the book was in the
because it like I said it was the same
woman that wrote the book but um yeah
they didn't mention they mentioned
cubing and all that kind of stuff but
they didn't mention that they mentioned
factor x that's what was it he would
work himself up into a fluffle what are
you working or something yeah I think he
meant to say frenzy but he said frizzy
into a frizzy yeah yeah he said he
worked himself into a frizzy yeah I was
like like a frizzy perm
[Laughter]
yeah and like I said so I don't know if
he was trying to say frenzy and he just
misspoke and then they I think and the
term he made up maybe he did kind of do
like a sexual frenzy I think it was it
was free it's a frizzy maybe it feels
like bubbles in years I'm like like you
know like like a fizzy like it's it's a
combination between frenzy and fizzy
yeah like a soda stuff like that yeah
that's how I'm pitched so it's like a
Portman I'm trying to channel [__]
Dennis that you know what it wouldn't
shock me because he did come up with
like all these weird little turns of
phrase and that was one of the weirdest
things about like reading his [__] like
reading his letters and stuff it's like
it almost had to be like decoded because
they had all these weird little yeah
terms for everything Dennis was about
emotions and feelings and all just about
himself other people didn't exist he was
just his own little fantasies and his
feelings about him
and he's trying to be all helpful in it
you know being polite oh all right good
afternoon you know
just trying to be a great subject
because you're talking he's talking
about himself
yeah which is really the only the only
topic that matters yeah at least in his
mind yeah he's trying to put his best
foot forward like I said with the
authorities when I was researching
Gerard Shaffer just BTK should have kept
coming up because
this dude like I said is very much a BTK
type a little bit of a Ted Bundy type
too but you know in the sense that
in the sense that he targeted like he
kind of the same kind of women and like
I said the whole beheading thing and
necrophilia and all that and he was kind
of um Gerard Schaefer was kind of an
okay looking dude and like he seemed to
come across like you know he had a job
and he was married and [__] like that so
it's kind of similar in that way as well
and I want to say he was
Charming but he wasn't really like he
wasn't overtly a creep but even back in
school like some of the girls were like
yeah he was kind of a creep yeah you
know what I mean like he wasn't weird
looking or nothing but
he was kind of a great Blake the way he
acted
but I don't know so all right so we'll
get into that
uh in a little bit Mr 88 said one what
yeah Mr Eddie I was gonna quote him good
one non-official Schaefer victim had
been picked up by a guy named Gerard her
sister was suspicious and wrote down the
guy's license plate well that's
interesting because yeah because one of
them's um her mom wrote down the license
plate and uh they and then she went and
like found the dude's address but yeah
we'll talk about that later Mr 88 was
also saying that
I think it was two I think he jerked off
on Vicki Weger because at least they
they found the DNA on her I'm pretty
sure yeah and then the little girly huh
yeah the first one the oteros yeah and
he
he did it when he could evidently and
there I don't think there's any proof of
some of the other ones because he moved
those bodies
so you would well he didn't usually the
only one that he moved was the one that
he took to the church and that was
because he wanted to take pictures of
her yeah I don't think there's any proof
that he did anything to he didn't jerk
off to that one but some of the stuff he
got interrupted too
if I remember correctly
um some of them he just had to kill
early didn't he
um a couple of them well it not so much
interrupted but like things like he
would plan stuff and it never didn't
turn out that way and he was and it was
[__] up because he's saying and
they're like almost like it's a big joke
oh things never went out it went the way
I planned you know what I mean like he
would always plan it's like oh I'd watch
this woman for a long time and she lived
alone and she was always alone but then
like the one time that he broke in there
like you know she had a date or her
brother was over or something like that
that he wasn't expecting right
um you know or there was a dog in the
yard that he didn't know about or
something so it's like like I said he
wasn't as [__] bright as he thought
he was not by a long stretch he was uh
I analyzed what he was doing
he was just making custom bondage porn
with this yeah he was like snuff poor
yeah he wanted to get pictures of him
looking scared but I don't think he ever
got that
no what was that that was that other guy
um he wanted to see a certain look on
their face
but evidently he didn't bring any
cameras with him I don't know why he
didn't
and then um he took pictures of that one
yeah that was it they take pictures of
himself
and he tried to put himself in in the
position of the victim kind of like he's
buried himself alive and all tied up
he's head Bond as fantasies about being
tied up which like I said a lot of
people have that and there's nothing
wrong with that but it's just kind of
like because this guy had the same thing
uh and it started young like I said
that's another thing that reminded me of
vtk bro
um killing him yeah he he
he got off on knowing that you're gonna
die that's that that angle so
he was a little kid he was when Des was
a little kid they tied him up playing
cops and robbers that he's pretending he
was going to die and that turned him on
yeah because he had the ropes on him oh
I'm gonna die and that was arousing yeah
that's what started it which is a little
weird but he started killing cats and
hanging cats ropes and [__]
and uh which if I had to caught him
doing that as a kid I'm just like well
we're just gonna snuff that kid out
right now it's evil save some uh save
everybody some trouble later on because
that's gonna end badly
um but yeah I just you know because that
that that just never ends well if you
have a kid doing that kids just don't do
that [__] normal kids don't you know
what I mean not like that
like yeah a lot of them will like you
know burn ants and [__] like that that's
not that big a deal but
the [__] that they did that he did was
no that's a completely different thing
because that's like a complete lack of
empathy and a complete
um wish to have control over
someone weaker than you yeah which like
I said that never bodes well
and and they don't I kind of feel like a
lot of people don't grow out of that
like or don't get out good over that
that's like a really bad sign
uh Mr 88 said Schaefer does have the
Henry Lee Lucas problem in that police
likely attribute too many cases to him
but unlike uh Henry Lee Lucas Gerard
definitely did kill more people hard to
unravel after the fact yeah um he
definitely did yeah Henry Lee Lucas like
I said I think he only killed two or
three people oh speaking of Henry Lee
Lucas um at least indirectly that was
another thing that Gerard Shafer said he
said because I think he was also in jail
with um Otis tool you know Henry Lee
Lucas's bud and he said I saw like some
parts like some uh clips of some of an
interview with Gerard Schaefer and he
said that Otis tool was his fuckboy in
prison and so he had all the dirt on
Henry Lee Lucas like I said I don't know
if any of this is true or if he's just
yeah if he's just like blowing his own
horn because the weird thing about
Gerard Shafer is that not only and I
guess like serial killers are like this
BTK was kind of like this but I feel
like Gerard Shafer was like
kind of like the epitome of this where
he wanted to be like the world's best
serial killer so a lot of the [__] that
he was talking about
um like I said he would name drop like
more famous serial killers like oh Ted
Ted Bundy said he was homaging me like
with this murder like he totally ripped
off my murder you know what I mean like
this the ammo he would say [__] like
that and he just sounded like a [__]
Edge Lord is what he sounded like and he
and he was very big on trying to
shock people
you know what I mean so and I'm not
saying that he didn't kill a bunch of
people because I'm certain that he he
most certainly did but a lot of it might
be like 80 to 110 that might be an
exaggeration although it wouldn't shock
me if it wasn't but I do kind of feel
like it might have been an exaggeration
because he was very much into which like
I said we'll get more into this later
but he would write short stories ever
since he was young like ever since he
was a kid he would write like all these
quote-unquote short stories about all of
his fantasies and pretty much all of
them were violent misogynistic like you
know killing women and raping them and
cutting their heads off and eating them
and [__] like that and he wrote [__]
like that all the time and he would send
them to
he had an ex-girlfriend like many years
later like she had been his boyfriend
like they've been boyfriend and
girlfriend in high school and she became
a true crime writer later on and they
collaborate on a book and he published
all his stuff and she I've seen
interviews with she's a little bit of a
nut too because she ended up with um
she ended up dating Danny Rowling for
Christ's sake too like after like you
know the Gainesville Ripper so she's
like making her way through all the
serial killers which that's a whole
other kettle of fish right there but um
but she said like in some interviews
she's like I just got the sense that not
saying that a lot of the stuff in the
stories wasn't true or wasn't stuff that
he'd really done because I'm sure it was
but um she said I got the distinct
feeling that he was trying to shock me
disgust me so he was trying to go like
as far as possible like he just seemed
very
and he came across like that in his
interviews because there are a lot of
interviews with him because he likes to
talk about himself just like BTK did but
um yeah so he so he was just very much
the kind of
uh I mean I'll get into like some of the
[__] that he said
and
while I don't doubt that he did do
horrible [__] like he said some of it he
might just be exaggerating to sound like
a quote unquote badass you know what I
mean it just kind of gave me a whiff of
that as well but he did bad enough [__]
like in real life but I think he
exaggerated Tom
it's kind of like badasses run around
doing what these guys do yeah that's
what see that well that's what makes me
angry about like I said he's a Chumps
man yeah it's like you guys know it's
like these are like the worst of the
worst they fascinate me
but they fascinate me because they're
the worst and I'm just like what the
[__] is wrong with these people because
it's like they just they're just not
wired right you know what I mean so it's
like so so that fascinates me the fact
that they're just that there are humans
that are just that deviant that would do
that kind of [__] but it was like so
it's bad enough that they do the [__]
that they do but then to be like an edge
lordy arrogant douche on top of it it's
just like that's
that's just kind of like the cherry on
the [__] Sunday as far as I'm concerned
you know what I mean yeah the most
successful one would be Ted Bundy and he
was weak
I'd [__] that dude up maybe Stronger
Than a Woman
and he used weapons I believe too he's
guns on them and [__] yeah this guy did
as well yeah and then um
D'Angelo probably physically was the
closest you gonna get to a badass
he was doing some pretty hardcore [__]
doing stuff
run around
in the middle of the night any middle of
the day armed going into people's houses
setting it up you know it's almost kind
of like Commando raids leaves trained
cop in I believe he was ex-army too
wasn't he I think he had been in the
military yeah he's the Marine Corps or
Army yeah I thought he was a marine but
I could I could be remembering so you
know he had the background and
he had the physical strength you know
and the discipline to be a soldier at a
cop so that'd be the closest you're ever
going to get to a badass would be
D'Angelo
D'Angelo was a badass don't let him hear
that yeah yeah but he's old now
he was evil
yeah the the stupid thing about it and
this just kind of applies across the
board not just his serial killers but
any time that you're a serial killer or
any kind of criminal like that and
you're talking about what a badass you
are and basically you're just tying up
and raping and killing teenage girls
yeah
how much of a badass can you really be
killing those killing those people isn't
what made D'Angelo a badass though it
made D'Angelo badasses that he actually
had physical strength enough to fight
men and uh he could pass oh he was Navy
he was Navy Navy okay he could pass Law
Enforcement Training he had balls but he
was evil you know what I mean his
motives were cowardly
yeah you know he didn't go up against
other armed men
yeah
which why didn't they do that yeah why
don't you just do that and then put it
on have sex with it and then put it on
pay-per-view and then we can all watch
you all kill each other yeah everyone's
a winner
but um you know it was only fun when the
other guys are armed or [__] can't
hurt you that's like a duel right
everybody's everybody is if if it's too
much in your favor then that's that's
that's no thrill everyone's [__]
name's got to be on the menu
death's got to be equal opportunity you
know what I mean
yeah I mean what's his name [__] Mark
Twain said [__] once you teach young
men how to hunt and kill each other
armed men they never really get out of
it they
you know nothing's ever really the same
they'd like that
but I don't remember which war he was
talking about
but uh that's where a lot of those
cowboys and a lot of those mercenaries
and [__] over the years and pinkertons
and [__] [__] they came from that
kind of background
World War II guys
they were badasses when they came home
Mr 88 said panzram is the guy that
walked the walk no Administration yeah
that dude was a lunatic he wasn't really
a human though he was more like a devil
a demon from the bowels of hell he was
created in hell
and those [__]
orphanages he is probably we've done a
show about him but he's probably one of
the most extreme cases that I've ever
read the dude was just he had absolutely
no Humanity no whatsoever no and uh
making I don't even want to call him an
animal because that's an insult to
animals it was a weird thing about him
is that he had no interest in women he
just wanted to rape men and make other
men rape other men and shoot guys if
they didn't have sex and [__]
was a nut
a nut yeah he was a completely didn't go
after little girls just men and boys I
completely Interstate yeah like I said I
think he had of all the he hated men
killers that we've talked about I think
he had like the least Humanity I don't
even think he was human at all anymore I
don't know how physically strong he was
I've only seen pictures of his face and
stuff but in those days most people were
pretty
poverty depression and [__] you could
tell he was a lunatic just by looking at
his [__] face like looking at his
eyes
there was just nothing in there
he just seemed completely like Soul
lifts you know what I mean I'm just
using that as a term I don't really
believe in Souls but you know what I
mean I do I know you do yeah I'm just
saying that I'm just using it in the
yeah kind of more he was a demon
colloquial sense he was created as a
demon yeah
and you know like I said we and we talk
about this a lot because I'm kind of
fascinated by the whole nature nurture
thing
I mean with the particular case of
panzram yes he had a horrible upbringing
a horrible upbringing like an
unimaginably horrible upbringing but the
thing about it was that you know and I'm
not diminishing it I'm just saying that
a lot of other boys had that same
upbringing and didn't turn out like that
it was just how he reacted so there has
to be another Factor
you know there has to be another Factor
well there's always just going to be
variations
in in results
you beat nine dogs that way not all the
dogs will turn out the same way he was
just one it didn't turn out like the
other ones yeah you know
because you know everyone's different
and you never know how one person's
gonna react because the thing about and
you know to kind of circle back around
to
this [__] that we're talking
about Gerard Shafer he had a pretty
I don't know if I'd say normal childhood
but not that abnormal and I feel like
BTK was the same like he had a pretty
just normal it's nothing no real like
egregious abuse or
anything like that there was really no
indication
um that anything would go awry
necessarily
um you know like I said it wasn't a
fantastic childhood but it was just like
you know it was just pretty average for
the time I would imagine so it's not
always
sometimes people are just [__] up you
know Mr 88 said panzram was ripped
I didn't go back to see him
yeah it said he was completely honest
about what made him him yeah he was he
was
I mean for somebody as monstrous as he
was he did seem to have something of an
insight about
why he was monstrous yeah he didn't care
though no but yeah but he didn't care
because usually if people are that
insightful that interest you know they
have some introspection they don't turn
out like that but because hatred for men
yeah and people in general because a lot
of times I think a lot of the problem
too is that and you can see this in a
lot of serial killer interviews some of
them do seem to have some insight about
what they do but a lot of times I find
that when they're talking sometimes they
reveal a lot more than they think
they're revealing by like the way that
they say things but because the thing
about it is that a lot of them think
that they're smarter than everyone else
so they don't realize that other people
can kind of like see through them
sometimes I think BTK had that problem
um you know some of the [__] that he
says I don't I don't know that he
realizes what exactly it is that he's
saying or that he's revealing you see
BTK you see him uh pictures of him when
he was uh basically arrested you know
or and going through trial he looks
pretty [__] bad you see when he was
young beat uh [__] Dennis was
actually a good looking guy
his wife and his daughter were good
looking
yeah when I saw his daughter I was like
man I couldn't believe it you know she
first of all she's normal
yeah and she was cute
I mean she's still normal
yeah I saw some interviews with her and
stuff like that I can't imagine what
that must be like yeah but
she I mean the wife never did come out
and I can't really [__] blame her to
be honest um
the wife was just like yeah I'm not I
don't want any part of that no no they
didn't they didn't
I mean yeah they were completely
completely shocked you know what I'm
saying this [__] had a um Gerard
Shaffer he had a wife as well well he
married a couple times he didn't have
any kids though yeah Camp guy's right
pants around wasn't a normal serial
killer he'd fight you in a bar and kill
you if you look yeah yeah Pan's Ram was
almost kind of like a damn old west gun
fighter he kind of had that because that
was 19 that was 1920s so it was almost
the same era it's kind of like an old
west gunfighter that had been perverted
into a now homosexual serial rapist and
murderer you know yeah he was just
[__] he was the mean faster he was
just like a mental kid yeah he came up
out of uh if you guys don't have seen a
prop show we did a whole show on
he was basically raised in orphanages
just being sexually abused by the staff
and the other [__] inmates that were
there or the kids that were there and he
just [__] grew up just being evil
just totally and he was going through
prisons and
prisons also and
every time you get out of prison he'd
[__] do worse and worse [__]
and you know he killed little boys and
men and bums make bombs have sex with
each other and then kill him and [__]
die he's [__] evil
take little boys out on a boat and
[__]
rape him
drown him
throw him overboard I think how do you
think threw him overboard weights on him
didn't he
uh if I remember we're gonna shoot him I
don't remember
yeah you know he was he was vicious
Mr 88 said BTK is also distinctly not
all that bright yeah that was one thing
that I did note um when I was reading a
lot of his stuff like a lot of his
interviews and stuff like that he
clearly thinks he's a [__] genius
yeah but he's very average but he's
really not yeah very average if not
below average a little bit yeah
it's just methodical
he liked to order he was that yeah
um he did [__] up though like a lot of
times but yeah he was like real anal
retentive about uh planning [__] I think
he was probably about average maybe a
little bit above average intelligence
now I think about
just he wasn't creative he was
he just put a box in yeah you know what
I mean kind of conformist in a way yeah
big time which is why he liked so much
that whole authoritarian mindset
and I think it's interesting because
Catherine ramsland said on there and I'm
paraphrasing because I can't remember
the exact wording that she used but she
said that
he um liked everything very regimented
so that he could go in there and
basically just like Break The Rules like
nobody else was allowed to we wanted you
to follow the rules she could go there
so he could go in there and take
advantage of you like that's basically
what I don't know if he would have
enough insight to realize that but she
realized that you know he said he was
always going in and out of the mode
right he'd be a normal guy and then he'd
become like like The X Factor he'd
become a Minotaur then he'd get he'd
walk away from it for a few years and
then go back to it as soon as he didn't
have time you know to do it yeah because
sometimes he got busy doing other things
right he had his Motel parties and all
that kind of stuff but yeah if you have
Hulu that's another thing I forgot about
that yeah I didn't know about
[__] Dennis would have Motel parties
and you're like well who's coming to
this [__] party just just him he'd
rent a room
to do his [__] thing and just and
jerk it and and she had to have a hole
and tie itself up and and he'd be there
for like a couple days doing that the
vacation with himself
in his suitcase full of stuff six
suitcase full of [__] masks and rope
and stuff mess and with makeup on them
and
lingerie which like I said look that
would be fine if that was all you were
doing if you weren't hurting anybody no
one was off the victim's lingerie though
wasn't it
well like I said if you just went out
and bought your own lingerie and wanted
to tie yourself up and put a mask on
like you know knock yourself out you're
not hurting anybody he had a whole
treasure map with dozens of dozens of
little stash points or he was stashing
all his
trophies that was another thing they
showed us an abandoned vehicles out in
[__] out in the woods and stuff
it's crazy yeah crazy he called him
hidey holes yeah
he's so it's funny because he's so
[__] in some in many ways he's so
Midwestern like I I commented at one
point where we're watching the show
um like the whole entire time that he's
talking I was like you know he'll murder
people but he won't swear right yeah
it was just like so weird to me yeah
like because I think he used some word
like he was like gosh blah blah and I
was just like oh yeah he'd say that
[__] can't do the same G will
Lookers right yeah yeah but he's a
[__] serial killer and then he can't
even say God damn it oh [__] I was just
that's why I don't trust people that
don't swear
I don't
[Laughter]
know I was like what else have you got
going on that that's like covering up
because that's like I don't know I just
I just don't I don't know
I don't know what that what it is but
it is but uh all right so yeah Mr Haiti
it said Dennis also almost fatally hung
himself on a scout camp out he couldn't
get out of his own noose yeah too bad
that didn't happen earlier but but yeah
he's still alive too and I think I say
that every time is he dead yet no
all right so let's start talking about
Gerard Shafer we'll probably talk more
about btk2 just because we'd watched
that too and I was like these dudes are
like kind of similar
even though this this dude is a floor of
me he wasn't born in Florida he was
actually born in Wisconsin but he moved
to Florida when he was a teenager
so yeah so this [__] uh Gerard
Shafer one uh documentary I said said
that he usually went by his middle name
which was John but I only saw one
documentary that said that so I'm just
gonna call him Gerard because that's his
[__] name and he's dead and he can't
do anything about it so um so he's born
in 1946 like I said in Wisconsin
now he was
um the oldest of his parents children uh
he had like two he had a sister a sister
and a brother or two sisters I can't
remember
so his dad was actually a traveling
salesman so he was gone a lot now as I
mentioned it wasn't a great childhood
but it wasn't like
a crazy like over-the-top sexual abuse
kind of thing now I will note that the
dad
um he you know like I said he was gone a
lot uh allegedly had a bunch of Affairs
like while he was on the road and stuff
and he was also an alcoholic so he did
kind of beat on
the mom uh I believe who was a housewife
and they moved around a lot
so they ended up in Fort Lauderdale
Florida in 1960.
now one of the things that
Gerard Shafer said about his childhood
was that he felt
neglected by his father like he felt
like his father didn't really give a
[__] about him or he was like the
red-headed stepchild
he called himself like
he called himself something like the
illegitimate product of a shotgun
wedding or something like that like
implying that I guess his you know his
mom got pregnant and then they had to
get married because it was back in the
40s
um I don't know if that's the case or
not but that was how he perceived it
so it seemed like he was always I don't
even know if he was even trying to
please his dad but he always felt like
his dad didn't really give a [__] about
him and always like favored his sister
now the fact that the dad favored the
sister
some people have speculated that this is
what first got Gerard into
um wearing women's clothing because he
much like BTK he was really into women's
underwear like he would go and steal
girls underwear and [__] like that so he
was like that kind of person and he
started to get like a sexual charge out
of that like from a pretty young age
evidently
he also said that whenever him and his
siblings were playing games as kids that
he always wanted to be the person like
if they were play acting games like cops
and robbers and stuff he always wanted
to be the person to get killed so he
might have been having like some I don't
know suicidal ideation or something like
that like from a fairly young age like I
said mostly because you know they're
moving around a lot his dad's kind of a
drunk who kind of beats up on the mom
his dad's not really paying attention to
him the only things that him and his dad
had in common
were a love for hunting and fishing and
so every now and then they would go out
and do that together you know what I
mean but he did feel like his dad kind
of like belittled him
all the time so he was actually much
closer to his mom that's again you don't
see that across the board in serial
killers but it is very common for people
that later become serial killers to have
like real either neglectful or super
super authoritarian or abusive fathers
and Brill overprotective mothers that's
a pretty common
family Dynamic and that seems to be the
case here
so like I said uh as he is getting a
little bit older he was really into
hunting and fishing he kind of liked
being out in the woods
sort of by himself I don't think he was
necessarily a loner like he did have
friends kinda but he wasn't real he was
kind of more a dude that sort of like
faded into the background a little bit I
guess
more than like he didn't really stick
out like in one way or the other I guess
now as he got a little bit older like as
a teenager as I mentioned this might be
a little bit because of the way that his
dad favored his sister and he was like
thinking oh if I was a girl my dad would
like me better or something like that
but he started having sexual fantasies
where
um he would do like peeping Tom kind of
[__] and he started having
um like just real violent fantasies
about
um you know hurting women and again like
a lot of male serial killers he had a
very distinct Madonna horror complex uh
And he as he got older he would off he
just basically would call girls [__]
[__] and they you know they would get
what was coming to them and [__] like
that one story in particular that
um one of his
childhood or teenage friends
remembered about him
was that he had a neighbor like when he
was a teenager he was about the same age
as him
and he believed that she was taunting
him by undressing in her room like where
he could see her like from the window
like he thought that she was doing it on
purpose like to tease him and he was
really really angry about this and
thought that she deserved to be punished
for it for tempting him or like being a
[__] that was like yeah how he thought
of [__] and like I said this is when he
was still
pretty young you know what I mean
and I think too when he was a teenager
he
started getting into
pretty extreme I guess like sexual
fantasies and I don't think he was very
old either according to a couple of
documentaries that I saw he apparently
had a girlfriend when he was 14 they
were both 14 and I they were together
for like two or three years
and either at his behest or because she
was into this which it's a 14 year old
girl I don't really know but it's
possible I guess
um they would get real into like violent
rape fantasies and these are 14 year old
like 14 to 17 year old teenagers so that
should tell you something right there
like I said I kind of think
I think he kind of tried to claim later
that it was all her idea like that it
was what she was into and so he was
doing it but
given his proclivities later on I
probably feel like it was probably his
idea
but yeah so much like BTK
um he got into wearing women's clothing
he got into doing
um autoronic asphyxia and he was also
real into like going out in the woods
and tying himself to trees
and you know that would like
make him bust a nut you know what I mean
tying himself to trees and doing and
imagining doing that to somebody else
yeah right
um and another thing too like like I
said in school he wasn't considered
he didn't really stand out although one
girl that had gone to high school with
him she's like she did remember she's
like he didn't really hang out with any
of the clicks like any of the guys or
anything like that
um the one thing that she mainly
remembered and I think that a lot of
girls that he went to high school with
remembered him for this too it's like
that all the girls knew that if he like
walked by or something that you had to
like put your skirt down like that
because he would like was real into like
looking up girls skirts and stuff so
they thought he was like a pervert like
uh like a creep and that was in high
school
now he like I said he wasn't a loner or
a loser or anything like that he was
actually
um his teachers seemed to like him
thought he was gonna go places like he
wasn't an amazing student but he was
like a real good he was a good student
um he was on the varsity football team
um and he was uh he did golf like he
played golf and he was really really
good at it some like sources I saw said
he was good enough to go pro which I
don't know if that's true or not
so he actually
um I think this is a Catholic High
School he went to to St Thomas Aquinas
high school because his family was uh
Catholic
so he actually graduated from Bay
Catholic High School in 1964. and then
uh went on for a little while to work as
a fishing guide in the Everglades and
then he
um got went and enrolled at Broward
Community College
now his first major was social studies
but then he decided to go into education
he wanted to get his teaching
certificate now see like I said this is
again much like BTK much like these
types of serial killers they always like
to be in a position of Authority or
power over other people so
um teaching would have appealed to him I
guess because he could
you know have authority over other
people and that's what he wanted
so he did okay uh in the education
program
and then he actually got a scholarship
for his remaining like two years to go
to Florida Atlantic University that's in
Boca Raton
now
so he does that now during this time
like while he was while he was still in
college or a little bit after he
actually married his first wife whose
name is Marty Fogg she was a student
also and she was two years younger than
him
now weirdly she I just thought this was
a weird detail
she was actually in a singing group
because you know this was like right
this was right around like 1968 so it's
kind of like the height of the hippie
movement right
so I guess from my understanding
that there was like a counter movement
among like I guess like real religious
or like super conservative people where
it's like we're gonna have our own
singing group like to counteract the
hippie [__] so I guess that the woman
that he married the girl that he married
was in that so he actually toured with
that with this singing group for a while
like going around doing these kind of
like I don't know if they were
anti-hippy songs but they were trying to
like counter the whole hippie message I
guess so yeah so they did that
so um these two did not stay married
very long
the problem seems to have Arisen because
one uh Gerard was gone all the time she
was hunting and then when he was home
all he wanted to he wanted to have like
rough sex and she wasn't into it
so
um I guess like he had all these kind of
things where it's like well you have to
put out you have to do what I say you
have to do this then the other thing
because like I said he seemed like a
very controlling dude dude had rules man
yeah well she didn't like the rules
um so after a while she divorced him and
the reason that she gave on the divorce
papers was quote unquote extreme cruelty
so I don't know exactly what that meant
but I could probably I can imagine ah
some sexual [__] probably yeah what is
going up in here I don't care what you
say about this well he might have been I
mean like I said considering like the
[__] that he did later on he probably
wanted to like [__]
right it's like we gonna get that up in
there somehow right it was probably some
[__] like that yeah well like I said a
man like just considering what he would
do later on yeah I imagine he probably
wanted to
tie her up and do like well look like I
said his I don't know if you were here
when I was talking about it but his one
of his teenage girlfriends like when he
was 14 to 17.
they were all in often to like rape
fantasies so I'm assuming that he wanted
to do some [__] like that and she grows
into it too well that's what he said but
I kind of suspected that is not the case
so that might have been what was going
on here and she's like yeah bro I'm not
I don't really like that
yeah
um okay so then this is crazy like
considering what what happened later
March of 1969 he actually gets an
internship like a teaching internship at
Plantation High School
and he first starts out teaching
geography
now he was only a teacher at this place
for
like less than two months
because it turned out that he was
um just super arrogant super aggressive
um he wouldn't listen to anything that
his Superior sold him like I said he was
just an intern he was just out of
college you know what I mean and
um he was attempting to
uh Force his own
questionable morals on the students and
there were many many complaints I don't
know exactly what he was saying but it
was apparently not good because a lot of
the the parents uh of [__] like that
were complaining
so um
hey Victor Victor's showing up so he's
here to tell us what turned him gay
we'll find out this episode he's always
got a different excuse
yeah
like and Booty's got nothing to do with
it on Victor all right
yeah okay
so um so yeah basically the guy after
they fired him from that position
um the guy that had hired him was like
yeah that was a big [__] mistake and
he
what the hell it's a dog oh
okay that's a little yappy dog a little
yappy dog outside I didn't know what
that noise was
but the guy that um hired him and then
subsequently fired him was basically
like
um and so this guy must have been bad if
even from this early early stage because
he's like
um if I ever hear that this guy is put
in a position of authority over anyone
like I want to hear about it so I can
put a stop to it and I was like damn
is she in that oh she's in the litter
box what is it it must be it must be
Dakota
because I said I don't think Pookie uses
that one
she uses the downstairs one
[Laughter]
she's making a huge yeah making a huge
racket in the litter box just for some
reason there she goes yeah well I
thought oh no I thought so you only had
to show her two or what so she knew
right where to go she's like oh okay
yeah yeah we didn't put this one up
there so because I didn't want her you
have to use the same one as Pookie
because I thought they would be they
would fight over it
um but yeah so then after he gets fired
he applies for another student uh
teaching position
um but they didn't give it to him
however four months after that
he actually did get another teaching
internship at a different school so he
started teaching geography again at
Stranahan High School
um and this place
also after a short time was like man
this dude sucks like he didn't they said
he had very limited knowledge of the
subject that he was teaching which was
geography he's like where is this are we
in the United States what country is
this you know what I mean it was I don't
know if it was that bad
um and they also said that he was uh
very arrogant
and so basically they're like what
did you Garcia he answered I narrowed it
down to early 90s Keanu Reeves is what
made me gay that's a hell of a man
you could shoot man he could shoot I've
seen him at the range
and he could ride motorcycles and it's
all about motorcycles okay go ahead
thank you that dude's good he's good
shot man I've seen him shoot live at
live ammunition
AR-15s [__] pistols everything
it's never going to be like you know
that movie that he did those movies but
John Wick yeah John Wick that's
unrealistic [__] but
awful cool that [__] can shoot
so I will hand it to that yeah that's
what made you gay
yeah okay yeah definitely
so yeah so this [__] gets fired
from another teaching position for
essentially the same reasons
and then he goes allegedly over to and I
don't know if this was I guess this
wasn't with the singing group because I
think this was after his divorce but he
actually went to Europe
in North Africa for a little while
like not long but then he came back to
Florida
and then he started working as a
security guard a little bit again
there's that Authority thing and he
actually
um decided that he wanted to be a cop so
again much like BTK uh wanted to be in
authority over people tell other people
what to do have power for other people
very very common these types of killers
so there was a open position at the
Wilton Manors police department
which is actually
um which is just like a suburb of Fort
Lauderdale I think which is in South
Florida in case you didn't know
um so it's like a small it's not a huge
crime place or anything like that
so um he goes and applies there
and on his application he does not tell
them that he had been fired from the two
teaching positions earlier
uh so he basically made up
the job that he'd been doing I was like
oh yeah I'm a research assistant at
Florida Atlantic University like he did
go to that University but he wasn't a
research assistant he just went there to
teach and they were like yeah you're
fired
um so yeah they didn't uh check so you
know that was their first mistake and so
he actually got into the Broward County
Police Department that was September of
1971. and um he went to the little
patrolman school and all that other kind
of [__] and uh graduated from there so
he was 25 years old at this point Mrs
Broward Broward County yeah yeah
so
uh at this point like I said his earlier
wife had divorced him because of Cruelty
now before he started working as a
police officer uh in early 1971 he
actually met a woman named Teresa Dean
this is when he was still working as a
security guard she was 19 at the time
and uh they got married that year
um now apparently this marriage went a
lot better because this was a lot more
submissive woman and she would do
whatever he said which
apparently that's what he wanted that
made him happy so you know
now this dude so Schaefer only worked
for Wilton Manors the police department
for only six months
he actually got a commendation like they
did a big like drug raid or like a drug
bust or something like that and he
apparently did something like cool or
hot [__] like during that so he got like
accommodation for that but literally a
month later
he got fired
um because what they discovered that he
was doing was that he would pull over uh
female drivers uh and then he would get
all their information look up their
information and then later call them up
for dates
damn which uh you know you're not really
supposed to do that you know for the
obvious reasons so they found out that
he was doing that
um and they fired him
now
so he actually
got into you would think they didn't
really check back then I guess it was
the 70s they didn't have the internet
and everything but still it's like how
these people just fail upward like this
is mind-blowing
so he actually got another job as a
deputy and this is with the Martin
County Sheriff's department and he got
this job in June of 1972 and what he did
was he forged a glowing recommendation
letter from the last police place where
he'd were who had fired him for being a
[__] up
but he forged it and nobody checked so
they gave him a job
he was doing yeah
I guess they figured
who would Forge a ship from a [__]
other police you know what I mean who
would have the audacity to forge a
recommendation from a police department
him yeah and it worked but they would
yeah that's why it worked
they didn't think maybe I kind of feel
like maybe people were a lot more
trusting back then well well I was kind
of um thinking about that earlier
because you know a lot of the some of
the women that he killed
like he got them when they were
hitchhiking which we'll get into in a
second but
um and I've written about a lot of
serial killers who picked up people just
because in the 60s and 70s like nobody
gave it a second thought like nowadays
nobody'd be [__] horrified like no
way am I [__] doing that Jesus Christ
I heard a story of a guy who
was the con man
well he was in prison he's got his hands
on all these damn Medical
manuals and learned everything about
medicine got out of prison
forged up a bunch of [__] and got a job
as a doctor in a hospital and [__]
practiced yeah many years before they
caught him
dude it happens for the first time he's
doing surgery well Frank Abagnale if
you've read the book Catch Me If You Can
he did that [__] too and he flew
airplanes yeah like jet airplanes like
you know like commercial jet
Jets yeah [__] like that and he did
surgery he just learned it learned it on
the fly yeah
just because he was ball he started just
doing check fraud is what he was doing
yeah but he would just go in and say he
was all I wanted to do I've been wanting
to do a show about that guy for a long
time because I read his book He's
fascinating but if I remember correctly
the guy who got the job at the hospital
and he was in charge of other doctors
too eventually
um just wrote up a [__] fantastic
resume
claiming to come from [__] fantastic
schools and all kinds of [__] and then
you can check
yeah because they would I guess they
thought
how could you lie about this you know
how could you lie about being a [__]
nowadays they absolutely will check
could you imagine that dude the first
time he had to do a heart surgery
and never had any experience
he's just doing it because he read about
it can you imagine being that patient
and yeah and knowing that or like
finding that out later read about it and
knew all the [__] and I guess the nurses
did all most of it you know all the prep
work and everything and
and evidently he had a reputation of
being a good doctor isn't that funny
that was packing I think in the 80s of
the 90s
I mean sometimes you had a real good
reputation
he wasn't
he wasn't doing anything criminal other
than practicing without a license and
lying well that is Criminal but you know
yeah it's critical but I'm just saying
he really was working yeah you know it's
not like he wasn't like he was stealing
the body or anything he was he was doing
it yeah that's true it's not like he was
just like I'll be in the break room yeah
he's just sitting there bye-bye
and he doesn't show up for the surgery
since he was working right he was doing
the job
Camp guy said delivering a baby might be
one of the easier things to do if you
don't have any complications yeah but I
mean if you do have complications you
better know what to do because that
would but you know what I mean
I wouldn't risk it but you know I'm not
I'm not an arrogant son of a [__] like
a lot of these dudes are whether it's
like oh yeah I could do that I could do
that dude picked a specialty and learned
all about it and went out and did it
which like I said you know at least he
put in the effort yeah so they said he
could talk to lingo like I said it's not
like he was just trying to fake his way
through [__] yeah he did the doctor said
he did actually learn yeah doctor says
yeah he was a doctor yeah he could do it
well I mean that's how they learn [__]
too I mean they got to learn [__] from
books and I mean they get to like cut up
on corpses and stuff which you probably
didn't get to do but go to med school
yeah he just read about it and did it
I got a respect for that man well like I
said ask himself off it's a real okay
this gets me back to another [__]
story that's like this
we had a guy in the 101st
who he had a brother
it was a younger brother
he didn't know it but his brother stole
his ID and used his ID in his social
security card and his social security
number and his name
to enlist into a reserve Airborne unit
it was it was the one 163rd
he was doing training jumps
firing weapons jumping out of airplanes
on his brother's ID he had never been to
Airborne School
he had never gotten never been a basic
training he wasn't a soldier
but he had heard about it from his
brother
and then just read about it and then
took his brother's social security
number and ID and went and and so he
they figured it out eventually because
paychecks were being paid to an active
guy and a reservist
that had the same social security number
so they did an investigation and found
out they were brothers
that's weird huh could you imagine never
jumping out of an airplane before
and having no training to do it and just
Faking It
and and doing it and jumping out
I wouldn't even jump out yeah for any
reason so no I can't imagine that
[__] that yeah
that's a trip yeah Camp guys talking
about uh talking about birth yeah they
cut the vagina at the bottom sometimes
to give the baby more room to get out
yeah they do they do that in a lot of
cases actually yeah so back up though
well yeah they're not going to leave it
like that yeah but I know they might
[__] might heal on its own no
but Mr 88 said my eldest son was
delivered by a C-section but the
anesthesia completely missed however my
wife would wouldn't let them put her
under until she heard our son cry
that's hardcore
that's hardcore but yeah they do I don't
know how how common it is but I think
it's very very common that they cut the
vagina open so because pretty much
everybody I know that's had a baby had
to have their [__] sound back up
yeah not fun
glad I never went through that [__]
so uh so yeah all right now now we're
getting into the abductions now
the thing about this [__] is
that
no one's entirely sure because they
don't know how many people he killed so
they don't actually know when he started
killing so usually when people talk
about this case and what I'm talking
about this case it's easier just to
start from here because this is kind of
the first egregious thing that he did
and he got caught and then like later on
they kind of went and then he did some
[__] after this which
there's a whole situation about that
which we'll get into but he might have
done a bunch of [__] before this too but
they didn't find out until later on and
they still actually haven't found a lot
of the bodies either
so there's that
but this is how he ended up getting
caught so we don't actually know how
much [__] he did before this
so this happened on July 21st 1972.
so Gerard Shafer sees two teenage girls
hitchhiking their names are Nancy
Trotter she's 18 and Paula Wells they
are 17. now they're actually not from
Florida um they had come here on
vacation and they were just like you
know hey they were staying with a friend
or something and they were just like
going to the beach and [__] like that
like you do when you come to Florida
now he was on duty that this day so he
had his uniform and the police car and
everything
he pulls up to them they were coming
back from the beach
and he's basically like you know
hitchhiking is very dangerous especially
with [__] like me on the road that
should have been the end of that sense
but um he's like you know hitchhiking is
very dangerous and you shouldn't do it
he actually told them that it was
illegal in Stuart Florida where they
were which it is not technically or it
wasn't then I don't know about now
um but he told them that it was illegal
and they did they weren't from here so
they didn't know any better and he's
like um I'll tell you what the um if
they said something about they were
going back to the beach the next day and
he's like I'll tell you what I'll give
you a ride you know back to your
friend's house now just so you're not
hitchhiking so you'll be safe because
I'm a cop
and tomorrow I'll pick you up and take
you to the beach so you don't have to
hitchhike again tomorrow
now the girls like I said this is the
70s a lot of people hitchhiked you know
they're teenagers and he's a cop so
they're probably thinking oh it's fine
it was not fine but
well yeah we'll get into that
so he's like yeah I'll pick you up
tomorrow and take you to the beach and
they were like okay that would be cool
so the following day he had arranged to
meet them at this like Band Stand or
something like that like at nine in the
morning
so the girls are there waiting for him
and he shows up only today he's in
regular ass clothes and in his regular
ass car which is like a bluish green
Datsun that he had
and they're like bro where do you know
where's your cop car oh I'm working
undercover today he told them
so he just has his regular clothes on
and that's why he's driving his regular
vehicle
um so yeah but so you're still it's all
good
so the two of them get in the car
and then he says to them oh you know you
guys are tourists here so you should see
some cool [__] like in Florida back here
in these Woods or whatever there's this
really cool like old Spanish Fort like
we should go look at it
like uh it's on uh near Hutchinson
Island
and they're like um yeah sure okay that
sounds cool or whatever
and then he starts then it starts
getting a little bit weird like they
take him take it take them to this place
and it's just like this old Shack or
whatever and then he starts saying stuff
about
um them getting sold into white slavery
okay yeah so there's that
and um and then you know [__] starts
getting like really threatening so he
like takes him out into the woods
and then he put handcuffs on them and
gags
then he took them
to this place where these like big um
cypress trees or mangrove trees that
have like if Jesus Christ this is
[__] loud outside yeah um they have
those big roots that are like above
ground you know what I mean if you
haven't seen those
and he would
put nooses around their necks this is
why they call them the hangman
and he would make them like balance on
this
um root of the tree so like if they
tried to get out or they tried to if
they slipped off they would hang you
know I mean like he engineered it so
that would happen so that they couldn't
really move around like so he set it up
like that
so and like he had their hands cut
behind their back and he tied their feet
together and [__] like that so you just
had to kind of like stand there how old
are these girls again 17 and 18. okay 17
and 18.
um and then once they were both tied up
he basically started saying what he was
going to do to them but he was gonna
rape and murder them and like he was
gonna which one am I gonna do first and
like one of you is gonna have to watch
or he's gonna make them pick like which
one gets killed first that was a big
thing how did they fit into
he was just really into because like I
said how did he get him to pit
by basically well what do you mean
because you guys pick which one's first
yeah he just makes them pick yeah and
they come up with it yeah okay he gets
off on they had to force him to pick he
gets off on one of them like he
basically said something and like I said
I think I have the exact quote but it's
like further out of my notes somewhere
but um he's basically saying I really
and he really enjoyed like watching
quote unquote best friends like turn on
each other like kill her first you know
what I mean like I don't know if that
really happened or not but he really got
into yeah that
kind of like Dean Coral getting Brothers
to turn on each other yeah so that was
again that was kind of like another
thing of his power yeah oh another thing
too that I didn't bring up and a lot of
documentaries don't mention this but I
did like read a lot of his
um letters and their like stuff that he
wrote and [__] like that one of the
things that he liked best about hanging
was he was fascinated
by
basically if you ha if you hang someone
and they
piss themselves and [__] themselves yeah
like he he really got off on that and
like a lot of the gross like drawings
that he did which are online if you want
to look at them but a lot of them had
that like that he would have like women
and they were usually headless
then they would be like hanging from a
tree or something like that and they'd
be like they'd be like pissing and
[__] themselves because he was like
really into that I've seen a lot of I've
seen hanged bodies like from the old
west I didn't notice anything like that
in them he's probably making that uh
well I don't know I've heard I've heard
that it does happen sometimes
but he was real into well yeah that's
what he said he'd make them drink all
this water before he killed them because
he really got off on
uh
Tom Campbell said the new backdrop looks
good spooky thank you like I said it's
old we just moved the camera around but
yeah yeah it's the curtains yeah
curtains in a mirror satanic mirror
yeah so he's so both the girls are tied
up they're hanging there they can't
really move or they'll you know the the
noos will pull
so he's basically gonna rape and murder
them and then
Saved by the Bell
he gets an urgent call on his police
radio
which she had with him
and he's basically like [__] gotta scoot
but I will be back to do all of the
things that I said I was gonna do so he
left him up so he left him there yeah
um and he's basically like don't try to
run away because I'm not going very far
and I'm coming right back
um he's like I gotta go I gotta go talk
to the dude I'm gonna sell you guys to
that's basically what he was saying like
that kind of [__]
now I think he was gone for like two
hours I don't even remember what the
actual call was or anything like
in that ensuing two hours the girls
actually managed to escape now I know
like one of them I've heard it a couple
of different ways
I heard that Nancy escaped first and
basically the other girl Pamela like she
couldn't escape she's like I'm gonna go
and get help you know what I mean so so
she left but the thing about it was that
she couldn't get the Cuffs off like she
got out of the Noose all right and she
got the
I guess she her feet were all right but
she um she didn't really know where she
was she said that I noticed on the drive
that we were on a peninsula so she's
like so I came to this River like a body
but I think it was the Indian River and
she's like so I figured if I just
followed the river then you know I'd
eventually find the road you know I mean
because I'd seen the River from the road
like on the drive there and she was a
really good swimmer so she thought it'd
be quicker if she got in the river and
swam so she swam with her [__]
handcuffed cup behind her back like just
with her legs and [__] like that so um
so yeah she did that
and um so she swam and swam and then she
when she was coming out of the river
um you know what a cop was there because
they'd been looking for you know in the
meantime they found out what had
happened and she's like oh you gotta go
get my friend like you know Pamela she's
still back there and they're like no
it's fine Pamela escaped too and she was
able to actually get to the police
station before so they were both they
both got away
so here's the fun
[__] up thing
when Gerard this [__] went back
to the clearing and found the two girls
had escaped
he calls the police station where he
works and he says to his boss who is the
sheriff Robert Crowder
this is the quote I've done something
very foolish you'll be mad at me
that's what he said
um and then he said well what I did was
I saw these two girls hitchhiking and I
decided that I was going to teach them a
lesson
but I overdid it
a little bit
did they believe this [__] story [__]
no all right
what the [__] kind of story is that
those girls getting get didn't get away
there to be dead yeah yeah they would
absolutely this is what this wasn't his
first one
they don't they don't think it was okay
no this wasn't his last one which like I
said okay this is [__] up but they
think that he did some before this but
they couldn't prove it
yeah because this is clearly he had a
whole system going
so
the fact that he just called them up and
said that
I've just I've done something really
stupid I'm like yeah you have you'll be
mad at me yeah okay
so basically
the so the two girls made it to the
station like I said
and they told the sheriff Crowder they
told him everything that happened and
they knew the guy's name and they're
like they shared in the picture they're
like yep that's him
so when Gerard comes back and says
and tries to tell the story that oh well
I was just trying to scare them into not
hitchhiking like to show them how
dangerous they could be like the sheriff
is like [__] you yeah you [__] [__]
pretty much one you're fired two you're
under arrest so he arrested him like
right there
um so yeah uh charges against him were
false imprisonment and aggravated
assault
so they arrested him for that like right
no attempted murder guess because no
actions were taken but they were hung
right they were hanged the news around
yeah you'd think you think that would be
attempted murder but maybe I don't know
if it was because he didn't have a prior
criminal record or I'm not really sure
because because like I said considering
what he would go on to do after this
um it's kind of a shame and I know
hindsight's 20 20 and everything like
that but it's kind of a shame that they
didn't be like yep you're going to jail
forever because anybody who would do
that
um
that like that is a person that does not
need to be running around loose you know
first of all and
in Mississippi Alabama or Louisiana that
would be kidnapping kidnapping carries a
life sentence you can't take anybody
anywhere they don't want to be yeah I'm
surprised they did not charge him with
kidnapping maybe because it doesn't
matter that he's in uniform a matter of
fact that might that might be worse if
it's a sexual assault why because he's
using his authority yeah right yes
but this is the 70s they didn't have
those enhancements probably I don't
think they did because they didn't even
charge him with that even though he
clearly although maybe he could have
argued well they willingly got in my car
because I was giving them a ride but
then he took them somewhere else
right that is kidnapping but like I said
I don't think that they would have
charged him with that back then
Tom Campbell says he likes the new
backdrop thank you
yeah like I said it's kind of it was
it's always been there it was just we
yeah the camera wasn't in shock yeah
because we used to shoot from that way
going this way yeah yeah the other wall
you used to see is right there yeah
that's how that works yeah
yeah Mr 88 said he wasn't charged with
attempted murder because the Noose was
used to restrain the girls not to harm
them why he was not charged with
kidnapping is beyond me yeah same
yeah most southern states kidnapping is
life yeah and like I said because it
always leads to something like this
right I mean the laws might have been
more lacks back then I'm imagining
but yeah all they charge him with was
false imprisonment and aggravated
assaults think about why would you
kidnap somebody right it's gonna why do
you have to take them somewhere to do
something bad to them yeah 90 of the
time so that's life yeah come on
so they set his bail at fifteen thousand
dollars which
was a lot of money in 1972 or 1973 or
yeah 1972 but
still not that much considering the um
gravity of what he did
but because
um he actually paid the bail
two weeks after he got arrested
and his trial wasn't going to be until
November of 1972 which means this
[__] was running around free
until then
so he goes back to
um him and Teresa's house in Stuart
Florida
and
basically he went back and got a
different job like he got a job at like
a convenience store or check cashing
place or some [__] like that
now while he was on while he was
awaiting trial this is what pisses me
off and like I said I know like
hindsight's 2020 blah blah but had they
just denied him bail had they just
locked him up immediately
more people would be alive that are not
alive now because
a couple of months before his trial
which was set for November 1972 because
like I said he paid his bail so he was
running around loose up until now
a couple of months beforehand September
27 1972
he kidnapped
two teenage girls
Susan Place who was 17 and Georgia
Jessup who was 16.
now he didn't pick these girls up while
they were hitchhiking these two girls
were actually students at like an adult
education center they were there like
getting their GED
and he went there I'm not really sure
why he was there
like he obviously wasn't a student
um but I don't know if he was just
hanging out there if he had some other
kind of thing going on but he was there
and that's where he met them
now he actually gave them a fake name he
told him his name was Jerry Shepard and
he said that he was from Colorado
obviously all of this was a lie
um and he befriended them
they thought he was a swell guy even
though he was
considerably older than them I mean they
were like I said 16 17. he was 25 26
something like that so that's not a huge
age difference but um and especially
back in the 70s I don't know if most
people would have thought it was that
weird no man look I got out of the army
was about that age
girls that are 25 26 they don't want
anything to do with you they're going
out the guys are in their 30s that have
[__] money man I was getting fogged
on by girls about this that age during
that time you know what I mean late
teens
you know it
it's been up in the Boston area
the thing is though is that you can't
take them anywhere what are you gonna do
with them you can't take them to a club
yeah they're too young they're too young
you can't drink
and in that state at that time you know
what I mean they were of the age of
consent most of them you know 17 18 19
but they're you can't do anything with
them you can't take them anywhere right
so but the thing is is that they like
older guys 25 24 yeah
really that's not we got money and cars
you're not a high school kid you can
take them somewhere yeah you're a little
bit more mature hypergamy you know but
you just can't do anything with them
that's why [__] I know you guys some
of you guys in your 20s are [__]
suffering man early 20s for guys [__]
sucks because you're in an in-between
phase you can't compete with the guys in
their 30s and and the girls your age are
all going with them and the ones that
are younger than you you can't do
anything with them so you're [__]
until you start getting about 27 28 29.
then the ones in their early 20s 21.
they might be interested in you
and you can take them to the club you
can drink with them
really you know here in the US it's
about drinking age
that's one of the main factors
if you if you're if you're if you're
centered around Club game
you know
and me and Jenny were always we're at
clubs yeah yeah yeah so you kind of
needed to like you happy with somebody
that yeah could get into clubs at least
right
and a drink ideally yeah although they
didn't like you can get in a club at 18
here but you can't drink till you're 21.
and Boston you couldn't get in until you
were 19 I think you couldn't drink
couldn't go into a pub I don't think
until you're 21.
but a club you could
but then they had to put the band on you
yeah they had the band though so well
they have the um here they do the big
black X on your hand like if you're
under 21. if you're 24 25 your
girlfriend had a band on your arm they'd
look at you crazy yeah like oh come on
man are you robbing the cradle yeah even
though you're only like four years five
years older yeah well like I said so I
kind of feel like this is so these two
girls were older teenagers they met this
guy at this you know school or the
education center they were at getting
their geds
and like I said I don't I'm not real
clear on what he was doing there because
he was older and he was already out of
college but whatever
so um
so yeah so they started hanging out with
him you know played guitar did all the
[__] like you did in the 70s
now
on the day that these two girls
vanished
um
one of the girls moms
whose name was Lucille this is um
actually Susan's mom
she actually came home and found Susan
and uh and her friend whose name is
Georgia and they were in the room and
Jerry quote unquote who's Gerard
obviously were was there too
now they introduced Jerry to
Lucille the mom
and they said oh we're just gonna go to
the beach and hang out now a lot of
people because I saw some documentaries
about this and they're like well why
didn't the mothers of these two girls
report these two girls missing for like
four days or something like that until
after but the answer to that question is
that the girls basically told the mom
where they didn't say they were running
away but that's kind of what they meant
they're like we're gonna be gone for a
little while so she wasn't initially
suspicious but the thing about Lucille
was that she did not like Jerry from the
jump like she was introduced to him and
she's like I think the suit is sketch as
[__] so when the girls went with him
like you know to be gone for a few days
or to the beach or wherever they were
going she wrote his license plate number
down and his uh the kind of car that he
had which was like I said uh Datsun 19
from 1969 it was like a blue like a
bluish dachshund
so yeah so like I said she didn't get
super suspicious right away because the
girls had told her it's like yeah we're
we're leaving for a little while you
know what I mean
so they left that night
now four days passed
and Lucille starting to get worried so
she calls George's mom whose name is
Shirley and then she's like well have
you heard from your daughter and she's
like no and she's like and I haven't
either and she's like and I don't like
that dude that they went with so we need
to [__] do some [__] so they actually
went to the cops and reported the two
girls missing and she Lucille gave the
cops the
license plate number she written on the
description of the card description of
the man what his name was everything
like that
problem arose because I don't know if it
was I don't think that Lucille wrote the
tag number down wrong or if the cops
entered it into the system wrong because
they actually
um they matched it to like a completely
different car that didn't have anything
to do with anything like it was in
another County or something
and um the guy that owned that car
didn't look anything like the dude you
know didn't look anything like Gerard so
they were so that was like confusing for
a long time until they sorted all of
that out
now so the two of them
um you know like I said we're missing
and nobody knew what had become of them
like until later on
then only about a month later this was
October 26 1972.
two more girls disappeared while they
were hitchhiking these were younger
girls Mary Alice briskalina who was 14
and Elsie farmer who was 13.
um they were going from like a
restaurant
they were going to like I don't know
where they were going but they were like
hitchhiking somewhere
um
so the two of them disappeared and this
was like I said less than a month after
uh Susan and Georgia were last seen
now these two younger girls they found
their bodies
um early in 1973.
both of their they were found with um
both their legs like spread out really
wide
uh Mary Mary Alice her um she'd been
like bludgeoned repeatedly in the head
they found just skeletons or bodies
um well it was several months so I'm
assuming it was probably pretty very
decomposed yeah
um they found that a bunch of
fingernails were torn off her body
meaning she had probably she's been
tortured yeah or or she had been
tortured okay uh but they had both been
bludgeoned to death um they both had
like a horrible horrible skull injuries
okay so her fingers are broken off she
must have grew long fingernails was fine
yeah you think okay yeah yeah they
weren't torn out by the roots no I'm
saying okay no
so the cops after they found the bodies
they started asking around and Mary
Alice's friends said that her and Elsie
they would usually go to this apartment
which is in Lauderdale by the Sea and
the apartment was lived in by the older
sister of Mary Alice's of or one of
their boyfriends or something like that
it was like a friend of the family or
something
and that a guy that would come to this
apartment all the time was a guy named
quote unquote Gary Shepherd
so this guy was like kind of hanging
around all the time
and they're pretty sure that this guy
was Gerard because uh when they showed
the friends of the um murder girls
pictures of this guy they they were like
yep that's him and they said that he had
also claimed to be an ex-wilton Manors
police officer which indeed he was
so there's that
three months after that
uh January 11 1973. two more hitchhikers
uh Collette either it's either good
enough or good and now I'm not sure how
you pronounce her last name
and Barbara Ann Wilcox who were both 19
years old
they were actually hitchhiking in Iowa
in Sioux City but they were going to
Florida
um they actually made it they think as
far as Biloxi Mississippi that was where
they were last seen alive
now these two girls it should be noted
disappeared while Schaefer was still out
on bail
um you know because he hadn't gone to
trial yet or he hadn't gone to prison
yet for his uh for his kidnapping that
he had done because like I said at this
point that was all that they knew about
they didn't know about murders yet this
is all [__] they found out later
so they know that he made a phone call
Long Distance phone call from Cedar
Rapids Iowa to his house in Florida not
long before these two girls disappeared
from Iowa
Iowa so it's possible that he was out
and about
and you know and picked them up you know
what I mean they actually did find their
bodies in January of 1977 uh they were
again just skeletons now the two of them
were actually bound with bailing wire
and from the appearance of the trees in
the area it appeared that the girls had
been
bound to the tree
and there was also an orange crate there
that they thought someone had sat on to
watch them
dying like or was sitting there like
watching them like while he was
torturing them and [__] like that
because his Mo was very much to tie
people to trees or hang them like from
nooses from trees and [__] like that
they're pretty sure that Gerard did this
[__] too
um
so yeah because that was kind of his
thing he remember he did it to himself
when he was younger like he would tie
himself to treason he got off on that so
yeah
so finally in December of 1972
um Gerard shows up in court and this was
for the abductions the two girls that
escaped that lived
and his attorney they offered him a plea
bargain
which again crazy
but like I said they didn't know that he
had murdered more people while he was
out on bail like I said I know they
didn't know that but it's just it's
infuriating like to know that that
happened
so they gave him a plea bargain he pled
guilty to one charge of aggravated
assault and then got one year in jail
with possibility of parole after six
months and then he would get three years
probation that's it Cakewalk that's it
and that's for
kidnapping two girls no he didn't kill
those two but
it's obvious he was gonna do that though
yeah it's obvious that that's what he
was getting the girls could testify but
he took a plea deal so they weren't able
to testify they just bled guilty in this
and that and there you go right but uh
they should have gone to trial with that
and had the girls testify to what he
told them he was going to do yeah
because that's why what he was gonna do
they did testify at later like at the
murder trial yeah but at this trial like
I said it seemed like they didn't really
take it all that seriously what's up
Oracle how you doing girl yeah hey
yeah James homie home says dude's
[__] grin is horrifying major creep
Vibes yeah if you watch interviews with
this [__]
he's just ugh
like I said he comes across as very
arrogant and like proud of what he did
he comes across like like he's proud of
it like it was so awesome and so badass
and
so gross
so yeah
so Schaefer Goes to Jail Martin County
Jail
um in January of 1973.
and basically all he says and keep in
mind that he's allegedly killed several
people in the few months that he was
like prior to his trial for this you
know what I mean like because he was out
on bail
and they think that he killed at least
four people in that
time period
so he comes out of the trial you know
he's gonna go to jail and everything
like that so and he says to the
reporters I made a stupid mistake there
was no sex involved no one was hurt
oh so then it's all good I guess that's
what he thought
meanwhile March of 1973 uh Lucille plays
you know Susan place's mother
she actually was looking through her
daughter's things and she found a letter
that had been written by this Jerry
Shepherd person who had you know taken
her daughter essentially
and there was a return address on this
letter
so she's like hot damn and she drove
over there
confront the dude
so the address was 333 Martin Avenue
that was in Stuart Florida
and Jerry Shepard uh was not there
anymore because he was in jail and also
the apartment manager like the property
manager said to her oh his name's not
Jerry Shepherd his name is Gerard Shafer
that's who the apartment is registered
sale and uh oh and by the way he's in
jail because he just
abducted and attempted to hang two
teenage girls so that should make you
feel better
[__] sake
so basically Lucille and her husband
they're um driving around and like I
said they figured out right around this
time that probably the wrong license
plate because remember she had told them
the license plate of the car that they
had probably got the license plate wrong
so um because it had something to do
with um the different counties and like
the numbers that they used to be in like
they they thought it was for Pinellas
County it was like instead of Martin
County it was this whole thing
so she figured that out and then went to
the cops with the new information
and then when they looked up that plate
they found out that indeed that car was
registered to Gerard Shafer and that
that was his address but like I said
he's in jail at this moment
now they asked Schaefer about this and
he of course denied it up and down I
never met her I never met either one of
those girls blah blah
but
um when they showed the mom a picture of
him she's like yeah that's him that's
the [__] that was at my house
and that's who my daughter and her
friend left with
so then on April 1st this is 1973 now
there's um a dad and his son and they're
out looking for aluminum cans you know
like to get some money from the
recycling or whatever
and they found two horribly decomposed
bodies
uh and this was in okemic park in Port
Saint Port St Lucie Florida which again
is South Florida if you didn't know
now they found
um
this is [__] up so there were like
shallow Graves like some of the bodies
were like in Shallow Graves but
there were sections of the victim's
torso like tied to the trunk of a tree
so again
there's that kind of tying people to
trees thing
now one of the victims had
um still had jeans on that had like um
the Roadrunner on it you know the
cartoon character
um the other victim was found naked
so they're assuming one of them at least
was raped because the clothing was just
kind of piled up on the side
now these two bodies were found about
six miles
from where the two abducted girls uh had
escaped from where they had been hanged
uh and got away
so these two girls had obviously endured
a horrible horrible ordeal before they
died
um it appears as though like not only
had they been raped and tortured and
everything like that but they had also
been
cut up after death they were beheaded
they were sliced in half with the
machete all kind of other [__]
also I think at least one of them had
been shot in the jaw
so these remains were eventually
identified as those of Susan place and
her friend who had vanished before
so
yeah a 22 caliber pistol that's what was
used to shoot the girls and like I said
they were also cut apart and they let
and they knew that this was probably
that this was probably uh Schaefer
because they found
um like the the way the tree bark was
worn in there looked looked like they
had been tied on their lid just like
they did and also somebody had carved
the initials GJ into the tree
Gerard John I'm assuming
so
guess he wanted to like leave a little
Mark there or some [__] like that this
is the 13 year old and the 12 year old
no these were the ones that had that
were um
that were in the house that had met him
at the adult education center they were
16 and 17.
so yeah they did find their bodies
so now later on does he ever say what he
did
to these girls how it went down well
um or he's just he's gonna fast up to it
what he did well we'll get into that
we'll get into that a little bit later
because that's kind of like a whole
thing
okay so he does eventually talk about
this
sort of sort of what sort of
but like I said we'll we'll get into
that
I brought Dakota in here but she didn't
want to stay in my lap yeah that's our
new kitty ink machine we just adopted
her she told our Oracle about her a
couple of days ago got her at the mall
she's a rescue well at PetSmart yeah
yeah she was a rescue Kitty from um
hofmeyer animal rescue yeah which is
here I think it's in Leesburg she's 14
months old yeah and another mix yeah
she's a Manx like puke
it was all Destiny I said let's go let's
go let's go see we were talking about
getting a friend for Pooh yeah so let's
go look at the uh
PetSmart
we're gonna go see the Meg you know yeah
we were at the mall right so we went in
there and I saw a cat I lifted a cat the
cat made eye contact with me
and I said what kind of cat is that and
I said that's a Manx
I said when did he get here and it says
it got here today this morning she said
yeah
and I was and and I saw that the
adoption fee was a hundred
and I was like okay
and I said that cats it says we got to
see a movie we may come back and get
that cat
and we get into the [__] theater
we're waiting for the movie to start and
I said if that cat's there
when we go back after the movies we're
gonna get that cat so yeah we got it
was a Max it was there on the the day
that I showed up it showed up the same
time it looked at me I go that's the cat
and it was unusual because we were there
on a Monday because I was off work
normally it would be like a Saturday and
we we don't all we don't usually go into
the PetSmart we have before yeah because
it's right around the corner from
Books-A-Million we were in there getting
coffee so yeah
um
Zach says is she talkative yes the cat
yes so she calls for her friends at
night but they're not here
we are assuming that that's what she's
doing she didn't do it last night but
she did do it the first night she was
here it's quiet it's a sweet little man
yeah
like you okay yeah I'm okay yeah then
she kind of looks at you like yeah yeah
I was just talking I was just trying to
put put out a text you're not answered
yeah yeah because she came from a
shelter that had a bunch of other cats
yeah they were good to him at that
shelter
but we don't know how long she was in
there probably a long time I would
imagine because she was super quiet in
the box and everything you could put her
in a box you could drive her in the car
she wouldn't cry at all she's just
silence she just sat there yeah she
didn't try to fight she didn't try to
get out she's been in a cage for a long
time because we put her in the house
she's like wow the size of this place
she checked the whole place out upstairs
and downstairs and then now she's
confined to like the top step on the
stairs here she lives there
she loves upstairs yeah one little spot
then she'll go up and look out the back
window
right now she's running around the house
actually though
but she sleeps a lot eats a lot too
she's a little skinny when we first got
her she's very small
but yeah she's been eating like a pig
since she got here
straight he has got a Siamese says it
speaks full sentences yeah I've heard
that Siamese are very very one of the
best cats you could get very final Seal
Point chocolate points and stuff worth a
lot of money
real smart cats Maxes are right there
with them a little bit underneath I
think in terms of because of Siamese are
[__] real talkative and real
intelligent
yeah I always thought like puke is
pretty talking she doesn't talk loud
yeah but you definitely know when she
wants some [__]
[Laughter]
it's a little British honey cat
I mean yeah
we got this new one's a stubby Max it's
got a little four inch tail probably
yeah it's probably about half the length
of like a regular tape it actually who's
just has like a stump like that's that
long but this Kitty has one that's about
that it actually looks like a North
American Bobcat a little bit yeah it
looks like yeah
Oracle says my cat sneakers was a talker
as a kitten she once tried to climb a
bookcase and I got her down then she
muttered this string of noise that
sounded like I never get to have any fun
yeah
I can understand Pookie mace is she
makes it basically just makes kind of
like um
like little frustrated sound like if you
tell her no like something she wants to
like go in the closet and [__] like that
and you tell her not to or you drag her
out or something she's like
yeah yeah she gets all frustrated yeah
she's like I'm sick of this [__]
why can't I just do what I want yeah
yeah [__] yeah I want to go in
the closet
I don't know why she wants to go in the
closet so yeah she gets in there and she
was like oh okay nothing's here okay
she's like I thought it was gonna be
cooler than it actually is
yeah Tammy said both of my cats just
showed up at our house which doesn't
sound impressive Until you realize we
live in the middle of nowhere yeah when
I was growing up we always had cats just
show up randomly then we were like oh I
guess if you're in a country that's how
you get animals like in Heidelberg
Mississippi a little bitty town you
didn't have to buy animals they show up
cats dogs
yeah raccoons even
squirrels hey you got any food if you
feed them they just keep coming back
yeah yeah
all right so where I might need another
drink probably because I got a little
while left to go on the case all right
even though it's getting to be 9 30.
it's getting to be my bedtime because I
could get up real early but yeah so uh
let me
so um so yeah so basically what they did
at this point after they identified the
bodies
um they told Gerard Shafer about this
and they're like yeah bro I'm pretty
sure it's you uh so he asked for a
public defender now interestingly the
public defender he was given was a dude
named Elton Schwartz who fun fact ended
up marrying his ex-wife later on which I
thought was a little bit weird I mean it
doesn't have anything to do with
anything but I just thought it was kind
of weird
basically what they did because
um the situation
that the two girls had escaped and this
situation here with like the two murder
girls obviously very very similar
so they actually got search warrants for
Schaefer's car and his house and his
mom's house because they did find out
that he like stashed [__] there you know
what I mean
so they go through all of his [__]
now interestingly
when they're looking through his
mother's house
they found in a bedroom that was locked
they found 300 pages
of quote unquote short stories that were
also Illustrated like I said you can see
most of this stuff online
um that Gerard had written some of them
are handwritten some of them were type
written
um and they went back a while like he'd
been writing them for many years
all of these stories none of them were
normal uh all of them were basically
like
stories about
Horrors and [__] getting humiliated and
rapes and murdered
um you know but at the hands of a
quote-unquote rogue cop okay almost all
the stars as far as I know like almost
all the stories were in first person
and uh [__] like that
so some of the character names in these
stories
had names that were exactly the same or
were very similar to
girls that were later linked to like
that were missing or went missing around
the same time as he would have been
around you know what I mean so that's
why they think that there are a lot more
victims out there
um so uh so yeah so and one of the
things I mentioned this earlier but he
was real into hanging the girls up like
from a noose like he did to the girls he
abducted that got away
and then making them drink a whole bunch
of
fluids so he could watch them pee you
know what I mean like he's rolling this
weird fetish [__] he's real into that
also a lot of what this is like snuff
fetish yeah yeah I'm gonna die of Peace
simultaneously
I wonder if it worked
yeah I'm not about it he would lie he
would lie if it were
that's true I mean because you'd have to
wait a long time for the body to process
that
once you make him drink water
um wine or beer okay in the story okay
yeah these are his stories
yeah well well yeah okay you'll get into
it a little bit yeah we're gonna get a
little bit into that
um so another thing and this is
something that Ted Bundy did and um
[__] Green River Killer did this [__]
too or uh Gary Ridgeway
where he would at least according to
these stories
um that he would leave the bodies out in
the woods in like a week or two later he
would go back and have sex with the
bodies yeah Terry Ridgeway did that [__]
so yeah and [__] he was he was a
necrophiliac yeah allegedly weeks later
in the summer heat
and the cops would be like dude that was
like three four weeks later why'd you do
that and he goes it was free
I said Gary Ridgeway say because it was
free
that's some weird [__] man yeah
it was rotten too but it was it but it
was free
see that's what I'm gonna wrap my head
around the dudes are not wired right
obviously what nor what person their
right mind would even think of that why
would you even think of that
about
decomposing
the decomposing body also was erotic to
them it's just [__] unbelievable and
I never want to let people forget that
Ted Bundy did that [__] too yeah it
wasn't no sexy ass serial killer he was
a gross necrophone they kept women's
heads yeah and they got rice yeah right
they got rotten he's a nasty ass you get
kind of stale after they're all [__]
nasty I'm just saying that it's like
these are nasty [__] like I
said I do kind of feel like there's a
little bit of a thing where it's like oh
Ted Bundy and he's like he was so good
looking and bloody blah I'm like
[__]
[__] rotted heads yeah
irons and [__] [__] like that yeah
there's nothing sexy about that at all
and he was a [__] yeah it was a [__]
[__] that too
yeah so um so there was a lot of
necrophilia in the stories
um he was also real into
medieval torture that kind of stuff like
he was fascinated by that kind of thing
um they also found at this house which
is it's either his house or his mom's
house they found a whole bunch of guns a
whole bunch of hunting knives
um a bunch of rope they found a bunch of
porno magazines that he had altered like
that he had drawn in there to make it
look like the women in there were
pissing themselves or [__]
themselves or
you know there were headless or bullet
wounds or something like that no other
serial killer has mentioned this I this
is a fantasy he has yeah that he's
talking about well yeah I mean he talks
about it a lot like in his stories and
like I said he had like a bunch of
drawings that he did and like magazine
pictures that he altered
to get because he got off on that for
some reason
I'm not 100 buying it that it went down
that way when it was there this is
something I think he added to it
hindsight
that just I'm just not really buying it
well I will tell you that so they not
only found all that like just pictures
he had drawn and [__] yeah but they also
found a bunch of black and white
Polaroids uh 37 of them matter of fact
uh and several of these seem to show
women being mutilated okay
yeah well they couldn't tell
who the women were okay because they
couldn't quite see their faces
so they weren't so these were likely
like other victims they just didn't have
enough information to identify Polaroid
who developed them
it's a Polaroid it just pops out of the
camera that's what a pole right here
because there's a Polaroid company no
when people say a Polaroid they mean
that Kuching that just comes out I've
only seen color ones no they have like
well you can buy black and white
Polaroid film yeah yeah of course you
can I bought it before
but yeah you can you can buy Blackboard
shows black and white maybe you thought
it would be more Arty who [__] knows
the dude's a [__] lunatic
hmm
also this is special
um some of the photographs
also showed much like BTK although kind
of grosser I'm gonna say uh they had
Gerard there in his women's clothing
hanging from a tree like I said BTK did
that [__] too but it just as a special
little extra
um Gerard had [__] smeared all over his
ass see there you go there you go
he's got this as far as I know BTK
didn't do that he's got this fantasy see
he's adding that he's in Disguise he's
into scat and pissing and [__] which
loss of bodily control
I think that's what it is I think that's
what and I know that there is a small
subsidiation afterwards because look I
have been to
I I actually it was in Fort Lauderdale
now that I'm thinking about it I have
been to a fetish party where nobody was
doing that live but they did have like
some porn going on like up in the on the
TVs and stuff and some of it was scat
porn yeah and I was just kind of like
I'm trying to drink over here okay it's
just like I don't need to [__] see
that like it wasn't all over the kind of
[__] but because that's a very extreme
and it's kind of like a minority of
people that are into that I mean it's
like I said it's like everything else I
think it's disgusting but
if you're not if you if everyone's
consenting you're not hurting anybody
fine but it's just like I'm you know I
don't want to hang out with you or
nothing because I'm sure your breath is
terrible there's enough
what he's talking about kind of reminds
me of another fetish though I think what
I don't think he's so much into the scat
yeah element of it I think he's more
into the loss of bodily control that's
what I was gonna say yeah and there's
another something that's there's
something that's more because it's a
humility kind of like humiliating that
you couldn't hold yeah it's kind of like
back in that [__] you hold your water
what was that what was that [__]
[__] uh that was simple yeah
something like that there's a
there's a fetish a I think it's called
calismophilia clasmophilia something
like that where you just
where a woman fills herself up
it's usually a woman it's a guy puts a
woman in bondage
she's hanging from the ceiling or
something above a dab
plastic swimming pool child swimming
pool and he just keeps [__] filling
her up with an enema until she just
can't hold it anymore the [__] belly
gets inflated she's they're measuring
they make videos of measuring how much
water went in there
and the idea was is just until
she just can't hold it anymore
so yeah
that's what he's talking about yeah like
you said he's talking his big thing was
he was very
misogynistic yeah
he pretty much thought of almost all
women as [__] who were taunting him
with their sexuality yeah
um and he wasn't like he could
apparently get laid like he got married
and stuff like that but he still thought
of women that way and so I do think that
that he got off on the humiliation more
than anything he's thinking of women in
that way that's a fetish she has yeah
that's why he wants them to be yeah yeah
he's projected yeah he wants him to be
like that right he wants to be all these
[__] [__] they're just tempting him
yeah because like I don't know if you
were in here
um yeah when I was talking about it but
when he was a teenager like one of his
friends said that he got really angry
that this girl who was the same age as
him he was a teenager he thought that
she was deliberately like undressing in
her room where he could see her
to taunt him even though she was just in
her room like changing clothes like
normal yes right it's probably what and
he was like really angry like he was
like he was gonna do something about it
like she deserved to get [__] killed
these women these women they're out of
control trying to try to turn me on how
dare they
that's his thinking they're trying to
which like that's very common in these
types of rapists and killers and stuff
like that it's it's a weird
narcissism yeah BTK was like that too he
kind of felt like everybody and uh
Catherine ramslin like even pretty much
said this explicitly like he didn't
really think of any of his
victims as humans he just thought of
them as like projects is like something
to
um to just like he just wanted the
outcome he just wanted to like get off
and so it was just like a thing to him
like an object and it's almost kind of
like the part of the Madonna horror
complex yeah I mentioned that earlier
foreign guys from the [__] East all
right who are real religious all right
looking their main thing is they tell
some woman just why are you dressed like
that this is this is a while back this
is [__] 10 15 years I don't think
they're like that anymore [__]
because everybody's kind of moved
forward a little bit why are you dressed
like that you just run around trying to
seduce men
and you look at the girl he's talking
about she's just dressed normally you
know right
because because it's projection and
and
when you have guys to certain come from
certain cultures that are real
restricted they don't they they see
everyone is looking offending them you
know in their belief system yes that's
horrible self-absorption self-absorption
right internet I think has ended a lot
of that that no they're not doing that
to offend you they're doing that because
that's normal in their culture you know
well like I said I think a lot of these
types of it's a certain kind of mindset
you see it a lot in these types of dudes
yeah where they think people are doing
things at them right yeah well this dude
seems like maybe he was from some kind
of an environment where it was very
self-absorbed like you said
and almost kind of maybe uh
[__] cloistered in a certain way he
sounds naive
he sounds like a naive guy who's just
fetishizing yeah you know what I mean
well yeah because if you looked at if
you looked at BTK that [__] was
naive compared to me
and he's not [__] doing all this kind
of crazy [__]
he could not internalize reality
you know what I mean yeah you couldn't
see things for what they were
he wanted to see it a certain way he
chose to see it that way
part of it was I think something wrong
with his head and his brain but you know
he's a psychopath
but they got another second or something
there's [__] that I do that might fall
within the Realms of psychopathy but you
know I think I would be considered to be
out like a high functioning psychopath
if I was one
because I can care about people that I
know
you know I mean I'm good around children
I don't make those kind of weird
decisions like that but then I can be in
a military unit and [__] people up and
[__] you know I can fight and like
that and
um
so I don't know makes me wonder how
accurate all these [__] terms
actually are
but I've seen dudes like this and
[__] I've seen pathological Liars
granthers isn't here we grew up with a
pathological liar that we knew we were
in high school he's not in the comment
section
you know it when you see it
those dudes are different
and the same kind of mentality you see
in pathological Liars is the same kind
of mentality you see in serial killers
whenever I [__]
hear a serial killer see recordings of a
serial killer talking it reminds me of
the pathological liar that we knew yeah
I imagine there's a lot of overlap yeah
well because it's the same tone and well
a lot of serial killers I mean
particularly
um sexually motivated serial killers
which this guy is which BTK was
um they are very fantasy prone like a
lot of people have weird fetishes
there's nothing wrong with that I don't
even think that would be considered
abnormal because everybody's got their
thing you know what I mean it's like I
said as long as you're not hurting
anybody it's not a big deal but these
dudes
that's like all they think about like
they take it to like an extreme like I
feel like most people have like certain
things that they like but it's like
they're not spending their entire
[__] life thinking about it yeah
their life doesn't revolve around it
yeah like you know we we me and Jenny
have come out we're in the industry the
adult entertainment industry
[__] um and I totally understand the
science behind those products I also
know the effects that they have there's
negative effects that they can have on
people the thing is that's your choice
uh you don't have to watch that yeah you
know what I mean [__] it's just like
crack crack is bad but you don't have to
smoke it right okay
um I've done drugs you can do them and
walk away from them some people can't
and if you can't walk away from them
don't do them yeah it's probably better
yeah
and it's just uh oh [__] I forgot where
I was going with this what were you
saying before I was just saying that
um
just because we make some of these
products doesn't mean that we're
fetishized in it or think about it all
the time
for us it's just like a product that we
make it's like a lark
yeah you know we really do it
that's not normal life we're selling
fantasy yeah and it's fun we enjoy it
yeah but it's not and it's also not
normal sex though right
and it's the same when we're doing a
show on streamate our job is to help
these dudes [__] get out some
frustration so they'd Express themselves
I'm I'm
um and you know they they will turn
their cameras off we see who they are
they're just they're nice guys they're
just trying to get through the day well
they're just regular aspects regular
dudes okay and
um
it's almost just kind of like a service
it's not prostitution it's legal
it's they're just kind of like Custom
Custom to order live porn so Duke could
get off right and yeah we had
a couple a couple days ago we had a guy
up in England it was a customer it was
on us
it was wand with us for about 10 minutes
and they're like what's going on man I'm
in London
he didn't say London though he just said
England didn't he yeah he says I'm in
the office horny as hell so what do you
want us to do because it doesn't matter
he's [__] jerking it into office and
I was like man good for you all right
but he was honest about what the deal
was he just couldn't take it anymore
like I said he was so polite yeah
they're not they're not scuzzy they're
just like anybody else they got money
live show
yeah and some people are specific in
what they want and some people not so
much some people are like nah whatever
yeah but some people have very specific
things right yeah but like I said
nothing too weird we haven't got
anything like yeah everything's all been
agreed the only weirdest thing is we had
two requests to like me rough her up but
that's not that that's not that that's
pretty common I know how to pull the
punches but I need to pull slaps and
make noise and
it's it's acting yeah I'm not hurting
her no yeah yeah he wouldn't do that
right although it puts on a good show
they pay for it yeah we have four or
five guys jumping in watching it
throwing their two cents in
do this do that got a new camera [__]
to do cool with a light on it the light
on it has a ring light and a tripod
you're watching the through the new
camera yeah we don't have the ring light
on we have the big ring light on but I
don't have the ring light it's the the
camera has a little bitty ring light on
it's on a big long extension cord so I
can move it all around here get floor
shots up shots whatever
because I was doing that during certain
times and that that guy's going oh man I
love the camera angles because most
people don't or just most most people
that stream is a single woman and she
can only stream through her webcam so
she can't she can only give one angle
I'm going POV man yeah he's pulling it
off like a camera man yeah
up shots down shots [__] never
close-ups close-ups
and now we have one with a light on it
that's that would be better because then
it will because then it won't be dark
when we like pull it back because I'm
always the light good is the light good
please give me a thumbs up okay
Mr 88 said something new I learned about
sex from Tom and Jenny that I will now
search for a way to erase I guess he's
talking about the um
filling the the woman with fluid and
then waiting for it yeah yeah
I thought I'd probably inflation that's
[__] one I mean I didn't I'm not
gonna say I thought that was common but
I thought it was not uncommon yeah some
dudes are just I don't really haven't
eaten that much either look at her belly
you know it's usually some cute little
girl you know she's like I don't know if
I can take any more and he's like let's
just get another few ounces in there
[__] you know
it's kind of like something out of Fear
Factor like a challenge you know to how
much water can you fit in there
well like I said there's a lot of the a
lot of the porn and like and Tom watches
he'll show me this kind of stuff a lot
of it's like it's not even so much
arousing as it is just kind of like wow
like it's like like I said it's like a
challenge like hey check out this woman
she can stick her entire arm up her
[__] yeah all the way up to her elbow
and I was like yeah holy [__] look at
that yeah and she's like cute as hell
like I said fastly you're like God I
said everybody's good at something yeah
she's making money off that one skill
and she's doing it in the elevator with
her with her boyfriend like I said
respect making money hey if you can find
if you can do I can't do that
not that I've ever tried I'm just saying
it's like I don't think
my tire on my man
she practiced
yeah she's like I'm gonna be the best
arms sticking up my ass person It's
gotta be something means there's got to
be some kind of jeans for that yeah
she's thin or something so you know yeah
all right so where was I yeah so we got
to get back to this because otherwise
I'm gonna we'll never get I'm gonna be
up all night and yeah where's this
cursor at how far down are we that's
right there okay good good we're making
progress all right yeah okay so when we
last
went off off the rails yeah
we were talking about them searching
this motherfucker's house and finding
all of his stories and his drawings and
his weird pictures and [__] like that
like I said oh the the [__] smeared ass
that's that's where we got distracted
I found a jewelry box
inside this jewelry box they found
jewelry obviously and also some other
pieces of clothing
um passports IDs that kind of stuff
belonging to several teenage girls and
young women some of whom were known to
be missing and some of whom some of
which belonged to
uh women that they had found murdered
uh they did actually find a like a
sort of like a um like a necklace or a
bracelet charm that was heart-shaped uh
that had the initials MTN on it
um they said they found that they also
found uh a gold locket with the name Lee
on it and it so happened that when
um Gerard was younger
uh he had a neighbor named Lee Hain line
bonnades
and she went missing in September of
1969 and they never found her so they're
assuming
that um he did something to her although
as far as I know they have never found
her body but they also found driver's
licenses belonging to
um two girls who were hitchhiking
Barbara Ann Wilcox and uh call it uh
good and now and uh they had both been
reported missing in January of 1973 so
their IDs were both in his house uh they
also found some teeth and Bone fragments
on the property as well
so again a little suspicious
now um they also found another a couple
of human teeth that he had like in this
little
like case like he had him special
which is [__] up
uh so yeah they also had uh Georgia
Jessup who was one of the girls that had
been uh abducted you know like I said
the mom had she was there in the house
and they said hey this is Jerry we're
going with him to play guitar or
whatever
um she was one of them they also found
her
suede purse in his possession he had
actually given it to his wife Teresa as
a gift
um shortly after the bodies of these two
girls were discovered he called his wife
and told her to get rid of the purse
um but she didn't what
kitties yeah yeah
um but yeah so he tried to say oh it's
it's a different purse or some [__] like
that but obviously it's [__] the same
one so yeah so at this point
um the investigators think they have
enough evidence
to
at least connect him to nine murders
considering all of the stuff that they
found in his house his mom's house and
in his car including bone fragments
teeth uh IDs jewelry belonging to people
that they knew were missing or murdered
so they thought nine uh between 1969 and
1973. now a newspaper or magazine
later that's right around that same time
they actually published a list of 28
people that either were missing like
they didn't know where the bodies were
or had been murdered and that was
unsolved that were close enough to his
Mo to make them assume that this is
probably the same perpetrator you know
what I mean
um so yeah that's where the 28 figure
comes from
um as far as I know I think that mostly
came from the media just them trying to
like link these missing persons cases
the cops at this time were saying nine
that they thought they could
definitively link him to but I'm sure
it's probably more than that
so uh in May later that month
uh Gerard Shafer was formerly charged
with first degree murder for uh the two
murders Susan place and Georgia Jessup
because those they found the bodies they
had all the evidence they had these the
two moms like Tracked Down the dude they
had seen him uh you know he was the last
person to see them alive and all of that
kind of stuff so they had like the most
evidence you know what I mean
so they sent him to
the infamous Chattahoochee which is a
city but like if you live in Florida
especially when I was growing up and
they said they're gonna send you to
Chattahoochee because that's like a big
famous like mental hospital like up in
the Panhandle
um so yeah so they sent him there uh for
psychiatric examination
um they basically said that he was
suffering from psychosis duh
paranoia and acute sexual deviation
um but that he could still that he was
still sane and could stand trial
he was trying to like get sent to a
Hospital instead of jail but you know
what I mean
um but yeah he basically denied
everything and he was just like um no
this is just all a terrible mistake um
I'm totally innocent blah blah
so he goes to trial in September of
1973. now at the time and this is not
the case anymore but in 1973
um the death penalty had been suspended
because uh the Supreme Court the Florida
Supreme Court had deemed it
unconstitutional so the most he could
get was like you know life sentences
basically
um so basically he pleaded uh not guilty
and just kind of South he did not uh
testify or anything like that uh of you
know to his Council advised him not to
so he didn't
he did testify at a pre-trial hearing uh
where he basically just said he was
completely innocent and they asked him
you know obvious questions like hey
where were you when this murder happened
or something he just would use the I
don't remember defense which you know
that that never [__] flies
so the jury so after the whole trial and
everything like that
um you know I read like a big long thing
of the trial but it's not it's basically
just going over most of the [__] we
already went over so the jury
um deliberated for about five hours and
then came back to guilty verdicts first
degree murder
and basically
um after that the dude Gerard he didn't
really get like all upset about it he
was just kind of like oh well that's
kind of how the cookie crumbles type of
thing uh he said I had a good defense
but I'm innocent that's what he said no
you're not no you're not
so he got two concurrent uh terms of
Life uh imprisonment
and again he was trying to like Lobby to
get sent to a psychiatric hospital
instead of prison but they were like uh
no sorry
so
basically okay so you think this [__]
story is over it's not so he goes to
jail
and
what ends he's he basically says I
didn't do any of this stuff uh the
prosecutors were quote unquote
overzealous uh law enforcement were
corrupt
um his own defense attorney Elton
Schwartz was conspiring against him and
as I mentioned his defense attorney did
end up marrying his ex-wife later on but
I don't think that had anything to do
with like him
try to get him and put in prison or
anything like that
so um
but he made up a bunch of stories too
you know what I mean now while he was in
jail let me say this
it's always a bad thing when if you're
in jail all of the other inmates [__]
hate you
all the other inmates hated this
[__] when he's a cop two he's a
rapist and a murderer yeah well yeah one
he was a cop and that's not gonna fly
yeah he's a rapist yeah
yeah and some of his victims were young
teenagers yeah oh yeah and also
um he was known as a snitch like he
always was like knocking on people like
to get special privileges and stuff like
that which is
um yeah other inmates tend not to like
that all that much
uh he also got in trouble several times
in prison usually he would be put in
solitary because he was trying to get
people to send him women's underwear
through the mail like into the prison
please give me some panties yeah right
right so like okay
okay now he wrote like I said he wrote
extensively all of these quote unquote
fictional short stories
he called it tiller fiction
and
even though
here's the thing
he kind of wanted I feel like he kind of
wanted to have it both ways he wanted to
be because sometimes he would just blow
his own horn about like I'm the world's
greatest serial killer bloody blah but
then
if somebody called him like a true crime
writer for example like called him a
serial killer he would sue them for
defamation like he was always filing
like frivolous lawsuits for people
calling him a serial killer one time he
filed a lawsuit I think just because an
author called him doe or fat or
something
um yeah and he sued because I mean they
they all got thrown out yeah what's up
warlock welcome to the show hey what's
up
uh but yeah the Oracle said I'm gonna
wander off y'all I'll see you all the
next Side Tracks no we'll see you later
yeah we'll see you Friday
um but yeah
so he was basically trying to sue
everybody while on the other hand
he wanted to be the world's greatest
serial killer but if anybody actually
called him a serial killer he would sue
them do you can't call me that that's
defamation funny which is [__] stupid
like I said you try to have it both ways
so what ends up happening is that
he um so all of this [__] that he wrote
he was approached by his ex-girlfriend
like his high school girlfriend I think
her name was what was her name Sandra
London or something like that
and
um
she yeah Sandra London that was her name
she had become a true crime writer in
the interim and when she found out what
this [__] did she started
corresponding with him in prison and
said you know do you want to collaborate
like do you want to publish like all
this [__] that you wrote you know we
could make some money if she could she
could make some money off it I guess I
don't I don't know what the law was like
in the seven because I know now I
nowadays at least in Florida I think you
can't make money like the person in jail
like can't make money like if I'm a
serial killer right like I can't write a
book about that [__] make a million
dollars like you can't you you can write
a book if you want to but all the money
has to go to the victims that's how they
do it which that you know that's fair
enough
you hear that cat yeah okay good what's
she crying about I don't know she's
calling her for her friends already
it's okay you have new friends now yeah
yeah just make sure she's all right yeah
I mean every single time she just talks
I don't think she's like in distress or
anything she's calling for her her
um
prison friends yeah
so so yeah so Sandra London starts like
corresponding with him and they're gonna
put out they put ended up putting out
like a couple of books the first one's
called killer fiction that was uh 1990.
and then they did one called Beyond
killer fiction which came out in 1992.
so these are
ostensibly fictional short stories
however
um almost all of them if not all of them
are in the first person almost all of
them have the main character being a
quote-unquote rogue cop and all of them
involve the horrible humiliation and
rape and murder and torture of women
that he calls Horrors and [__] and
everything like that but the thing about
it is that and a lot of the stories
detail
um
the details in the story like correspond
very closely to some crimes that he
never straight up admitted to but then
the weird thing about it is that
in some correspondence that he wrote to
her
uh he basically all but confessed to a
couple of the murderers because he said
oh well they keep asking me to confess
to things but it's like what is this he
broke this story called Murder demons
and she's like what does he think what
do they think that is so he's almost
like implying
that he just wrote about what really
happened and I'm saying I haven't read
all of the stuff but I did read portions
of it I wouldn't recommend it because
it's [__] up
but some of the stuff in there does
correspond very closely to some of the
actual crimes so while I think that some
of it was probably fantasy or probably
exaggerated I think a lot of it was [__]
that he actually did which is what makes
me suspect that he killed a lot more
people than they know about but see the
thing about it again he wanted to have
it both ways like he would say oh well
they keep asking me to confess to things
and I kind of already did that sort of
like he's kind of implying that he
already did that by writing these
stories
somebody asked him about well what about
this story and did you kill you know
this particular person that's missing or
so like oh it's just a story it's just
fiction so he wanted to like have it
both ways you know what I mean like he
wanted everybody to know like all of the
[__] that he did but then he wanted to
have plausible deniability about you
know I mean it was just like [__]
[__] up anything about those stories
well but the thing about it is
I bet you they went along the lines of
his fantasies yeah but that's probably
not how it the murder actually went down
well some of them were similar to the
way that they think some of the murders
did happen though well the situation was
probably right close but I bet you the
way what the victims did how they
reacted was not accurate and the things
that they said was not accurate
heavily censored and he added his own
[__] comments and [__] if there are
comments I haven't read
well this is one thing this is usually
the murder doesn't go down according to
Siri goes usually I mean even BTK the
murder doesn't quite go down the way
they fantasize about it
so they had to do it again they're not
really satisfied with that one why
the woman wasn't sufficiently terrified
a lot of times she fought back she said
insulting things to him well she was
dying [__] I made fun of his people she
made fun of him or or or like [__] you
you know she she didn't she wasn't a
willing victim she didn't play the role
okay so a lot of times they're like ah
that was no good we gotta do it again
well like I said that tells that story
he can't tell the story yeah she made
fun of me he's not gonna say that where
she told me to [__] off you know it's
not gonna that's that's not gonna be in
his version of the story right
that's what I don't believe serial
killers well they will see that's the
thing is that they spend so much time
wrapped up in their fantasy lives and
they have this whole rigid idea of how
they want [__] to go yeah and so
that's kind of going back to what we
were saying earlier about like what I
was saying about BTK because this guy is
kind of similar or he reminds me of him
is that they kind of it's almost like
they expect the rest of the world to
conform to their fantasies and they get
very very upset when it doesn't I'm very
surprised right I mean this goes back
all the way back to Albert Fish Albert
Fish did some nasty [__]
but he told stories about whole victims
that they don't even know they really
existed
like he told one story about how he
killed little black boy there was no
evidence of any little black boy were
being killed
he could have made that up at a whole
cloth maybe he did it or he could have
done it but he probably made that [__]
up because he was into [__] telling
stories and to make himself look as bad
as possible
you know it just well like I said I kind
of feel like this dude is along the same
lines because if your goal in life which
don't have this as your goal in life
okay but um if your goal in life is to
be I'm gonna be the best serial killer I
can be I'm gonna be the most [__] up
individual anyone has ever heard of ever
in the history of the world then it
would behoove you to come up with the
nastiest most horrible [__] and whether
and it's a lot easier to just come up
with it than to actually you know like
do it exactly another thing is is that a
serial killer in captivity
his power is these stories
if he tells you all his stories he's
going to lose his power over you the
Captor
so it's best for him to continue to make
stories he tells you what he did and he
goes yeah there's other [__] I haven't
told you about they just keep doing it
yeah they keep yeah and doing it they'll
just continue to make them up
if not then they'll become irrelevant
and nobody will give me any attention
and they won't have any power I will
give BTK credit that he actually did say
in his own words that the ten they know
about that that was it I don't know if I
believe that or not but he did say that
he didn't exaggerate it's probably it
but I don't think he was that prodigious
yeah maybe not he was too busy
he's too busy jerking off too you're
talking about he he told say he he
[__] admitted that I spent most time
jerking off
it's all these [__] relics that he
collapsed I wonder how many hours of his
life he's been jerking off go on to all
these little hidey holes he would make
rounds
throughout this can you imagine your
like entire life
jerk off material
which is like you know I mean it's nice
to have a hobby underwear goddamn yeah
yeah if you've seen the map like if you
watch the documentary you made like a
map of all these little holes that he
had where he had like all and some of it
was like [__] that he had taken from the
victims and stuff like underwear jewelry
or whatever yeah and so and some of it
was just other stuff like stuff he had
drawn or pictures he had taken or
something yeah and he would like stash
him around everywhere and he had the
[__] everywhere yeah he'd have him I
guess a little clusters and little
groups where oh this is this is where I
enact this fantasy and over here is
where I enact this fantasy
and you know some of them had
relics or you know items taken from
victims and he he himself said you know
jerking off saved a lot of people's
lives so he would continue killing a lot
of people yeah like when he was doing
his weird like Motel parties and stuff
like that he was doing that instead of
killing him like as like a yeah like a
Sav over it or something like that
because he went a long time and that's
they talked about that quite a bit in
the documentary how he was kind of an
outlier because he could go like several
years like without doing it anything
well
well he he basically admitted he said
these little missions of killing these
women
were difficult
well he's played the victim and it
didn't go a while on it and oh and I had
to wait in a closet for three hours I'm
like I know and I was like oh poor baby
oh man you know and it was just yeah
everything was Mimi I didn't plan on
this you know it was terrible you know
if I could oh yeah because it was just
from his point of view everything was
from his point of view yeah he was like
one of the most like self-absorbed yeah
he wanted you to know that yeah I did
all this [__] but it was hard and you
know what I mean I I was really stuck
out doing this
I didn't do it right the first couple
times and then it was so dangerous you
know
well there's something to be said for
that yeah man you're gonna get caught
doing that [__] okay yeah maybe you
shouldn't be doing it maybe you should
find a new hobby right you're not you
know it's it's dangerous doing this [__]
you're gonna run into some old some
woman's boyfriend he's gonna [__] you up
because or a woman with a big ass gun
yeah
it's gonna blow your face off that's one
thing you said I
thought shotgun but she didn't you know
uh which she should have she should have
grabbed that [__] shotgun if she
thought somebody was in the house maybe
she didn't have one maybe she didn't
have one but um
and Dennis who you see pictures of him
he looks quite spooky kind of but
actually Dennis was weak you know he was
not a big strong guy he's
he didn't work out or anything you know
he
but you know to a woman and especially
an older elderly woman oh well not
really elderly but a woman in her 50s
who doesn't work out he's a lot stronger
than her but in reality compared to
other men [__]
no
Charles Raider I'd run through three or
four of those Dennis Raiders Dennis
Raiders please call him Charles for some
reason I'm drunk but Dennis I'd [__] up
three or four of those
damn what is that it's a shame it's a
shame that
dudes as weak as that including [__]
Gary Ridgeway who was a [__] rat
little [__] slime ball a bug compared
to be killed all those women I can't
understand it you know
I don't understand it you know what I
mean he's stronger than he was stronger
than those women he strangled him but
it's terrible
well it's not like they're going after
[__] sumo wrestlers yeah anything is
it they're always going to go after
somebody smaller somebody's smaller than
that right because that's how they do
right they choose them that's why that's
how they select them
Mr 88 said Schaefer was the epitome of
the mega megalomaniacal
control freak like many serial killers
the only control left once they're
imprisoned is information so they make a
game of it yeah uh yeah
and then he said is bck the reason every
boy in the 70s and 80s could find porn
mags in the woods on every Excursion
probably exactly probably except
actually if I was a little boy if I
found
um Raiders [__] I wouldn't I wouldn't
consider that porn I wouldn't know what
it was
he'd have some pipes with some ropes and
some uh some hand drawings and some
cutouts of a some chick's face on a
three by five card
out of a magazine and like her stats are
written on the back and he would ride
around with it in the passenger seat of
his car and talk to it like it was a
real woman it's an index card right and
there'd be some underwear in there
stretched out because some big old
[__] nasty dude was in it you know
what I mean and I just I wouldn't
because I wouldn't know what I found if
I was a little boy I'd be like what is
this
yeah it's like this this is not this is
not a rousing whatsoever yeah this is
this isn't Hustler
this is not good yeah I don't know what
this is it's creepy that's all I know I
mean [__] this is in the 70s when I
was a little kid we even back then [__]
we thought [__] me and my little
eight nine ten year old friends thought
Playboy was weak sauce we're like oh no
we got a penthouse today that's the good
[__] it is the good [__] yeah
yeah that one's called um Playboy was
trying to be all [__] Swank I
remember and we magazine we like that
one
but yeah so um
DB Dragon says beating off another day
keeps the murder away yeah I guess it
does yeah I mean once a day that's not
that's not egregious but it's like I I
just wonder it's not even so much that
they're beating off like however many
times a day but it's just that their
whole entire routine like they have to
have all of these parameters in place
like before they can even beat off but
yeah because everything has to be super
specific yeah so they have to have like
this whole like side
it's like a part-time job yeah like keep
introduction sounds like too much work
you know what I'm saying stuff is a
part-time job it's too much that's
[__] fun it's like he's got to have a
[__] if you have to draw a map yeah
of all the places where you're where are
your [__] where you just stashed yeah
that's it's taken over your life okay
you got some help bro but yeah we're
talking about raider now okay [__]
Dennis Dennis was a control freak he
liked to consider himself very orderly
and in control and he had maps and
[__] books that had [__] codexes
in it and [__] bar graphs and all the
different missions he was running and he
had admission schedule it's like
something out of the military
yeah he was very organized because he
used ex-air Force so you know he knew
how to keep things organized and orderly
and
but you know
and he always and he said that even when
he during the years when he wasn't
killing people he always had like huge
lists of people that he was stalking
projects yeah he was gonna kill that he
was gonna kill that he was talking like
if the time was right you know what I
mean like I guarantee you he enjoyed the
planning stage yeah I guarantee you that
the fantasy that he was gonna do it was
just as good as doing it in his mind
yeah thinking about it yeah well yeah
they tend to enjoy that's why they keep
uh mementos from the people because then
they can go back and they can relive it
like in their mind and stuff yeah he
thinks he's the command though but yeah
so um so where was I okay so some of the
okay so this is like some of the [__]
that this dude said now this was in uh
correspondence that Schaefer wrote
two I think this was to Sandra London
like I said when they were talking about
his books
what's that free DVD Dragon man it
should be right bro you got it
wait where oh it makes no sense weird
fetish like getting off to a Subway
sandwich with a flashlight in it wrapped
away with videos that's what I mean it's
just now look I'm not hating like I know
everybody has like weird fetishes and
stuff but if you're a fetish like takes
up your entire life and it's just like
super complicated I'm just like it just
sounds like too much work you know what
I'm saying it just sounds like a job I
got simple fit it's just I guess short
girls with big boobs
[Laughter]
great calves just short big boobs
you've got a shirt that shows midriff I
[__] love it
yeah it's time it's like yeah it's very
simple he's a simple one very simple
so this is something that he said
he said when I nabbed Jessup in place
Susan place and Georgia Jessup those
were the two girls that he was convicted
of murdering I had been in the ghoul
game for almost 10 years
so I knew what to expect from these
juicy young creatures at the end
doing doubles that's what he called like
calling to killing two girls at once
which is something that he did quite
often is far more difficult than doing
singles but on the other hand it also
puts one in a position to have twice as
much fun there can be some Lively
discussions about which of the victims
will get to be killed first when you
have a pair of lively teenage bimbalinas
bound hand and foot and ready for a
session with the skinning knife neither
one of the Little Devils wants to be the
one to go first and they don't mind
telling you quickly why their best
friend should be the one to die
so he seemed to get off on
the having power over people and like
making them
turn on each other I guess whether these
fantasy aren't these real yeah whether
this really happened now it is true that
like a lot of the murders that he is
suspected of committing were two girls
at once so he did do that yeah I don't
think the girls cooperated in the way
that he wanted to probably not and then
what did he uh he what did he do to him
with a skinny knife
we'll see I don't really know because it
seemed like most of the well most of the
women now he did have uh several hunting
knives and he did have a machete because
some of the bodies of the women that
they think that he killed were cut apart
beheaded
maybe he beheaded them but
and we're and a couple of them were cut
in half that sounds like post-mortem
stuff probably I have a feeling that he
killed him by straggling him no well he
shot some of them and then some of them
were um bludgeoned to death okay like he
would beat them in the head yeah and
break their skulls fairly simple [__]
and I bet I bet you there wasn't a lot
of torture
psychological is what it was he probably
asked him all those questions but they
probably didn't go along with it they
were probably like [__] you you know I
you know
who's gonna go first and then they'd
probably just start screaming
yeah it's like I have a hard time
believing it most even in that situation
most people will be like yeah I'm not
doing that right yeah that's what they
would do they'd probably start screaming
and fight
it didn't go down the way that he wanted
it to he's make he's lying
not the way humans are
so as I mentioned earlier he was always
kind of uh name-dropping Ted Bundy and
he basically called uh Ted Bundy quote
unquote Tyro uh you know like a
which is like an amateur pretty much
yeah
um and he said I think I mentioned this
earlier but um he said that one of
Bundy's crimes he considered like a
copycat of his and he claimed that Bundy
even told him that he's like yeah I did
that in no monasteries and I'm just like
no I don't think
um
so yeah
so as I mentioned even though in public
he's coming out saying I am absolutely
not a serial killer I'm innocent of all
this stuff and all this other kind of
[__] but then he was writing letters to
this woman and
saying all the [__] that he had done he
said that he had first started murdering
people in 1965 when he was 19 years old
and I don't really see any reason to
doubt that
um he also confessed to a 1969 uh
kidnapping of actually two very young
girls uh Peggy Ron who was nine and
Wendy Stevenson who was eight uh he said
that he kidnapped them in Pompano Beach
and ate them
um he came out in public and said he
didn't do that but in a letter to Sandra
London he said that he had done that I
wouldn't believe that well like I said
it's hard to say because some of the
stuff that he did confess in the letters
they're pretty sure he did do that [__]
so I don't know how much of it is
um I got a feeling it is exaggerated
yeah the type of guy this is he's trying
to blow himself up into something that
he isn't he did some of that
but it didn't go down like he said it
did yeah it's like I said it's hard to
say because he was for sure like a
fantasist yeah because Sandra London
like after she'd been collaborating with
him for a while and then she came out
publicly against him and was like yeah
he's a piece of [__] or whatever and
then he said
he's in prison right and he says he
knows all these people on the outside he
knows satanists and people in the mafia
oh yeah and um people on the KKK yeah
yeah and I can have you killed just like
that yeah right you know what I mean
the Italian mafia is Catholics okay
they'd be the first ones to [__] cut
you up all right they weren't in they're
not in all that rape [__] and then
[__] the KKK is another [__] was
was basically depending on which one
there were three of them but [__]
they were basically Christian
organizations you know they just for
didn't like Catholics and they didn't
like blacks
although they they disliked Catholics
more than they than they dislike blacks
but no they weren't into that [__]
they'd [__] you up too he's [__]
yeah so that that actually made me laugh
when I saw that kind of thing that he
was like threatening people oh I know
all these satanists outside and they'll
sacrification I'm just like it would be
the equivalent of some black dudes yeah
I raped all these women and I'm
the [__] um what do you call them the
Black Hebrew Israelites coming after you
no they're not about that either okay
the Black Hebrew Israelites were not
about serial murder and rape and [__]
underage girls they'd [__] you up well
like I said I know I'm not and I'm not
trying to Discount
um the fact that he did commit several
murders I actually have no reason to
disbelieve that he probably did commit
at least
26 28 murders I I don't think that's
crazy but the fact that he came out and
said oh I did my own list and it's more
like 80 to 110 I don't know if I believe
that so I'm saying that he did do a lot
of horrible [__]
um it's just that he he's embellished he
just embellished and like I said a lot
of serial killers do yeah most of them
do it to a bit to a certain degree
yeah so
um despite all of the here's kind of the
shitty thing though it's like I guess
this is kind of a this is gonna sound
[__] up this is kind of a happy ending
I don't know if it is because because
he's dead they never could really find
closure for like a lot of the cases that
they wanted to find closure on that they
were pretty sure he was responsible for
but never really got him to confess to
or give them information on and [__]
like that
but on the other hand
um it was kind of like karmic Justice I
guess because
in 1995 remember how I said that all of
the other inmates at the prison like
hated his guts
in December of 1995 another inmate
stabbed the [__] out of him and killed
him yeah now uh stabbed him in the eyes
like multiple times
um also I heard that that slashed his
like mouth open yeah but stabbed him a
whole bunch of times
now
um they're not entirely sure like the
guy that did it his name was uh Vincent
Rivera he's no hero either he was also
in prison for like a double homicide
but
he never really said why he killed him
um there are several stories going
around some of the stories are just like
they had a fight over a cup of coffee or
you know he took the last of the hot
water and the dude was just like in a
bad mood that day and he wasn't having
it
the more common story is that he was
killed because he was a snitch
that was only part of it look
there's a tendency for people to
dehumanize inmates too and prisoners
yeah prisoners and inmates are they're
in there they've committed crimes
they do not like child molesters all
right because they have kids a lot of
those inmates in there all right they
also do not like serial
sex offenders like serial rapists
because those dudes have sisters and
moms and wives out there yeah that
they're you know were they're like wait
a minute hold on you're out there raping
and killing women oh I got a mom I got a
wife you know I mean you know and I'm in
here I can't defend them and they got
[__] like you out there doing
that [__] [__] you I'm gonna kill you
you know because he's he's locked up
he's worried about his family you know
what I mean all kinds of [__] can happen
you know
so no it's
a serial rapist that's not really a
man's crime from a prison perspective a
prison perspective would be like armed
robbery manslaughter murder one and two
but especially if it's between gangs
um
you know the battery so that kind of
[__] fighting
those are respectable crimes in prison
but not [__] like [__] serial rape
pedophilia
child rape no
that's garbage stuff you know it's
bottom feeder [__]
yeah probably he's talking all that [__]
especially if he's a cop
he's a cop and he's a cop in prison he's
got to blow himself up into something
that he's not
to try to be as impressive as he can and
as bad as he can in front of these other
inmates that hate him so as part of the
reason why I don't believe you half of
what he said yeah he killed those girls
but it didn't go down the way he said it
did
yeah like you said it probably didn't
and like I said I'm not trying to
Discount the fact that he did kill a
bunch of people because he did and he
and I'm sure he did horrible horrible
things to them because they know that he
did but yeah the way that he wrote them
it was probably similar to how it
happened but it was probably
self-aggrandizing yeah to a great degree
and it all had his fantasies were all
fulfilled and all those different
versions of the damn story
you know I mean part of this fantasy oh
yeah she pissed herself you know I mean
that probably didn't happen that was
just his fantasy
oh yeah she turned on her friend that
probably didn't happen either that was
just his fantasy yeah that's what he
wanted to happen that's what he wanted
it so then like maybe after he did the
actual [__]
he wrote about it and then changed the
details yeah he didn't like to defeat
what he wanted
so he could jack off to it later yeah oh
so he could feel like he'd achieved his
mission and he's a badass in front in
front of all these people that hate him
you know which I think that just made
them hate him even more because he came
across as an arrogant douchebag
I'm gonna have my Satanist friends kill
you in there yeah whatever Anton LaVey
man
[__] call the cops on you
I mean just like the [__] that he said
I'm just kind of like [__] horrible
but yeah I mean he would say other [__]
too like
um again kind of like bragging but he
would say stuff that was obviously like
calculated to shock as many people he's
like oh you know I've killed all these
people and he's like oh well I don't
feel like like one girl that I killed
like I was disemboweling her friend and
she vomited and choked on her own vomit
and died so that doesn't really count as
a kill yeah and it's like what if you
know and what about the pregnant ones I
killed does that count as two like he
would say [__] like that so it's like
yeah and it's like he did enough
horrible [__] so it's like some of that
stuff is like plausible that he did
something like that but he's probably
just saying that like I said just to
shock people it's like oh my God I'm the
[__] worst you know what I mean yeah
because it should sound cool as you can
right and he really does if you see if
you watch interviews with him his tone
of voice comes across very like that he
obviously seems like he's the coolest
[__] alive right and so he just
like comes up but it's like he doesn't
really seem aware
that he doesn't sound like the coolest
[__] alive you know what I mean
it's more likely that the female victims
even the Young The Young Ones zoned out
and [__] blanked out and he didn't
get what he wanted out of him it just
screamed
um
the other ones just fought him
and didn't go along with his little
fantasies
that's what probably what happens
I wonder sometimes in the other cases
that you hear about this sound a little
more
like the the women that actually
survived these attacks they don't go
along with any of this [__]
for the most part right
they don't they just kill me you know
what I mean go ahead and kill me then
it's that kind of mentality
yeah I do kind of feel like that's that
happens a lot yeah I mean if you're in a
situation like that a lot of times
they'll just be like that [__]
should have a totally foil the fantasy
of these kind of guys it's probably what
most of the women did is resist they
didn't play into that [__]
yeah I do feel like most people in that
situation would yeah
resist or just well they know they're
gonna die blank out they know they're
gonna die I think they blank out scream
and resist and
zone out and [__]
you know I I don't think they play into
that [__]
like remember that one guy the toolbox
murderers they had to tell the girls to
scream over and over again while they
were hitting them with a [__] Hammer
because after a while it was a scream
they just stopped yeah
because why would you like to do it so
it's not satisfying to them yeah it's
not as satisfying it's not the way
they're picking not the way they're
picturing because they get all those
type of killers get off on yeah
inspiring Terror yeah but it doesn't
actually happen because they go into
shock yeah and if so if the if the women
are not sufficiently terrified then it's
not working out for that people have a
defense mechanisms you know I mean
anybody who if you read books on torture
you know like what the Cameo Rouge would
do to people and [__] uh you know
[__] a Cambodian
Killing Fields type tortures where they
had systematic torture of prisoners
people under under torch or have the
ability to kind of like mentally Retreat
and zone out that you can overload a
person with paint where they can't feel
pain anymore
so
yeah cause it just overwhelms your
senses right so
I mean if you if for you guys you know
what I'm talking about you can get into
fights or you're fighting some dude
you've been punched [__] seven or
eight times and it just looks like the
camera shook you don't feel it
you know you might feel it the next day
sore as [__] that you don't feel well
they're going through even more of that
you know what I mean [__] it's even
worse so they can't really feel a lot of
what's Happening
their bodies just starts kind of the
Mind Retreats and the body just kind of
acts like a robot it's just responding
to what's happening
you know conscious thought really cry
isn't there so they're probably not
playing into the dude's fantasies
they're just
like a cat you know what I mean you take
a cat you start [__] trying to set a
cat on fire or something like that it
just screams you know it doesn't play
into your fantasies it's just you know
they had some [__] Russian kid that
was putting cats in cages and throwing
[__] gasoline out and set them on
fire videotaping it they eventually got
that guy I think he was Russian it was a
long time ago back in the old internet
back in the 90s
I think they eventually caught the kid
his cats didn't go along with anything
they just [__] screamed and died
that's probably how these those girls
were
they reminded me of that what's that
dude's name that Luke mignona or
whatever yeah yeah the one that that
documentary that they did don't [__]
with cats yeah
yeah the internet track that
[__] Dude too man
suffocating a little kitties in the
Ziploc bags and [__] yeah needed his ass
whipped
then he killed his Chinese boyfriend
yeah
little [__]
how to stomp that dude's head flat
there's been nothing left for him except
a greasy spot
and nothing of value would have been
lost yeah
DB Dragon says fetish should not be
project management I would not want to
do Supply Chain management for dead
bodies in the woods and sexually
promiscuous Subway sandwiches just beat
off and go about your day exactly like I
said if it's more than a few steps it's
just too much it's it's too much look
man a couple days ago
I came across this [__] again
I was watching some of my science
programs and they mentioned 1970s in
[__]
[__] levels of lead in the
environment with the [__]
Letty gasoline
and uh they were still leaded paint at
that time yeah I remember that
and you read about what some of these
dudes were doing in the 60s and 70s
you got man I can't be [__] normal
and my whole LED theory that I talked
about a long time ago it's all starting
to come together I mean a [__] more
modern people you know I mean of the
[__] 2020s doctors and [__] are going
oh yeah that that lad that came out of
that [__] gasoline that ship would
make you violent as [__] and make you
crazy
you know not everybody but certain
people would
get enough of it in their system and if
they came from a bad environment would
tip them over the edge they do [__]
weird ass [__] I'm thinking leaded
gasoline had a lot to do with this kind
of stuff yeah during this period I'm
sure that was a fact because it doesn't
happen anymore it doesn't happen at this
rate anymore
not these kind of sexual crimes I mean
it does but not not at this in the same
way and not in the same rate and it's
not the same kind of weird intensity
I think it's lead
yeah because obviously these people's
brains were yeah way [__] up
yeah I think so
lead poisoning
Mr 88 said the toy box killer is one
case I just avoid too sadistic and cruel
yeah I mean we did a show about that
didn't we yeah it was funny you look at
the dudes they're just [__] [__]
well like I said a lot of them are like
a lot of them are like that running
around picking up teenage girls and
[__] doing things like sticking ice
picks in their ears and [__]
breaking their elbows with hammers
in a van you know they think it's funny
that ain't normal man that's [__]
think [__] for that yeah
I think [__] leaded gasoline had a
lot to do with it I mean anybody that
gets
Amusement out of other people's
suffering
is suspect I mean they have people that
is not normal they have people that do
that today
but not at this level you don't find
these guys like you did back in the days
you know what I mean when's the last
time you've heard of a really absurd
crime like that yeah a long time and I
wonder sometimes is it just because
we're catching them quicker or but see I
don't think that's the case because I
don't despite DNA and despite better
investigative techniques and everything
like that I think the unsolved the rate
of unsolved crimes is just the same or
actually worse than it was back in the
day yeah I think uh the environment has
changed and that people have changed the
culture it's just different
it's a different world now and I think I
think lead had a lot to do with it
because see they couldn't come out in in
the day
they put lead in gasoline to make the
[__] it was a toxic waste really and
uh somebody they even got the guy's name
he came up with a bright idea of [__]
making it a tiny particle so that's a
lot that's the last thing you want to do
is to make lead into tiny Parts yeah
let's make it way easier to absorb into
the bloodstream
you take tiny particles of lead and put
it into fuel
so when you're burning it in your car it
makes the valves sound a lot
nicer when they close you don't hear
that tapping and Wrecking in in
old-fashioned Rocker Box style valve
trains this is before dual overhead cams
and also the lead builds up in those
areas and it gives a better seal in the
valve that's the thinking
that thinking is total [__] okay the
the the Seal of that valve in those old
cars wouldn't even make you gain a
horsepower
you know it wouldn't make a big
difference
and yeah in a car run quieter but so
what so what it runs quieter
you're blowing all these [__] lead
particles out the [__] tail yeah it's
like I'll take a little noise rather
than just like polluting the entire yeah
the lead is not destroyed it's just
blown out through the exhaust and then
it collects and all the urban areas and
just blows around and people are [__]
breathing it yeah along with the other
[__] smog because they didn't have
catalytic converters back then
you know and uh yeah leads [__]
dangerous it'll [__] make you crazy
as [__] just ask the ancient Romans
part of the reason why the ancient Roman
aristocracy was so [__] crazy is that
they had [__] lead pipes bringing
water to their neighborhoods so the rich
people were [__] crazy the poor
people weren't crazy
okay but that that ended up really being
a contributing factor to to why Rome the
Roman Empire failed uh lead poisoning
that was a contributing and they were
using lead as a food additive it
sprinkled lead on food make it taste
better then they'd had lead plates
because that made it taste better
yeah that's not just go ahead and drink
some [__] Mercury might as well
with a with a little arsenic Chaser yeah
but I think Victor said that's why the
boomers are [__] nuts
developers are
[Laughter]
that explains a lot of times
no they're [__] very crazy not all of
them but most of them most of them mrady
said it is hard to tell there are tens
of thousands of people missing since the
70s some probably many were victims of
people we can hardly imagine yeah it's
like I'm every time I go back and look I
always find
you know yeah there's cases from
nowadays like on but if you go back and
look like the [__] 60s and 70s
there's people missing correct and they
still don't know what the [__] happened
to them there's always going to be a
certain amount of them there were
accidents though well yeah that's yeah
that's true I mean they've had people
missing for years
and then uh a pond gets drained and
there's that person's car and they're
still in it and they accidentally drove
off the road and went to that Bond they
found somebody like that like somebody
saw it on uh Google Earth yeah they saw
the car in the car to water
I mean there's all kinds of stuff that
happens then they have people that
um
cars break down and then they walk out
of the car and then [__] they get
overcome by
could be you know [__] cold weather
there's all kinds of [__] that yeah it's
not necessarily they're not necessarily
all killed by serial killers but
there's other ways to die yeah but I
kind of feel like that might not be I
think it's probably more common that
like somebody did something to him I
don't know I think another real common
thing is is that uh they're in country
areas and the car runs off the road and
they're killed
on impact with a tree and the car sits
down there for [__] years and years
and they find the car the dead person in
it up in mountainous and Country areas
that's one way there's just a bunch of
different ways the statistics can all
add up some of it's murders that are
more for profit or boyfriends killing
girlfriends or you know [__] like that
and they get away with it
not necessarily a serial killer
husband's killing wives
killing husbands that happens too
just
some people go missing because they kill
themselves
yeah that can happen
although Mr idiot points out summer
accidents but a suspiciously High number
of those missing are females aged 15 to
25 not a high accident demographic yeah
right that is true well that's rape rape
and murder doesn't miss doesn't mean
it's the same guy doing that though well
the thing about well what's scary like I
said is that we've talked about a lot of
serial killers on this show I've written
all about a lot of serial killers but
there's always ones that I haven't heard
about
I think there's a lot of guys out there
a lot of serial killers out there that
only kill maybe two or three times and
then that's it yes and I think it's what
gets a lot of them those girls you're
talking about
just because the guy does it
once doesn't mean he'll continue to do
it it's got to be a spectrum disorder
that's what I would think
so yeah there's a lot of missing ones
but it's probably a lot of dudes that
did that
but which is I'm not sure if that's a
couple more scary or less scary I think
that's more scary it's probably a lot of
dudes did it but they only did it once
or twice
I mean that's enough times though if
you're if you're the one that gets
unlucky enough to get picked up by this
[__] yeah that's probably what
it means I feel like in the 60s and 70s
it was when everybody was hitchhiking it
was a lot of it was like yeah yeah
people that were hitchhiking or people
that were like truckers and stuff like
that I kind of feel like there was a lot
of them running around doing that you
did it once
you probably much more likely to get
away with it
if you continue to do it you'd get
caught and those are the serial killers
we know about
there's probably a lot more guys that
only do it once or twice
which like I said that's horrifying in
itself
that there's that many people it's it's
not surprising to me though yeah because
like I said I write about crimes all the
time so it's just kind of like well like
I said it's probably like a spectrum
disorder
they want they they they're thinking
about it they want to do it they do it
and they go that wasn't cool I'm not
gonna do that again
it's like it's like that
yeah hopefully hopefully I never get
caught for that one right there's
probably probably many more of those
than anything
I wonder yeah I would think so
I would think that there were guys that
are very borderline
and they and they just do it one time
and do it one time I don't want to do
that yeah and like like I mean I guess
that's possible it wasn't like I thought
it was going to be that that's what it
that's probably the way I imagine it and
then they go on to live a normal life I
would think that's probably likely
it's like I said that for something else
that's kind of [__] up to you or you
know they might be semi-criminals and
they get caught for something else
that's what I'm saying I kind of feel
like if it gets to a point of like where
you're murdering a stranger yeah
um you probably got some other [__]
going on may not be a stranger
maybe a girl you go to school with
something like that
I don't know it's still messed up yeah
well it's probably a young guy
yeah you're talking about 12 13 14. you
need to knock that [__] off that does it
fry what is what you're talking about
yeah
so yeah I guess we better wrap it up
because he's getting very very late and
I have to yeah get up very early in the
morning it's 10 30.
but yeah so
this [__] like I said
it's kind of a bummer that he got killed
and wasn't able to you know give
families closure about what happened or
you know if they didn't know for sure
that he had done some of these crimes
but on the other hand I'm kind of glad
the [__] got stabbed
and actually
um one of the victim's mom she said the
same thing she was like I kind of want
to send that dude a present yeah you're
like [__] that dude for doing that you
know what I mean everybody was just kind
of like good riddance you know like I
said the dude that did it was no prize
either because he was in prison for a
double homicide but he he did the world
of salad I guess all right if uh you
guys are listening to this recorder go
ahead and send us the [__]
um super thanks if you want to I think
it's a little green button there unless
the place is unless it's commoditized by
the time you hear this well no
demonetize just means you can't show ads
on they can still send a super yeah yeah
yeah that's okay you just can't they
just won't put ads on it because of all
right advertisers don't want to be on a
thing where it's talking about serial
killers but yeah so thanks everybody for
dropping by and listening to this
horrifying Grim show this evening
because like I said this was a dude I
didn't know a great deal about even
though it's in Florida it was a little
bit before I was born but still so yeah
this was like pretty [__] horrifying
so um yeah hopefully you guys can drop
by again on Friday night for the
Sidetrack show which is always fun we'll
have some drinks and we'll just talk
about whatever just pops into our heads
which is always a good time so hopefully
you guys can come by for that and we
will see you guys again on Friday good
night